COMMITTEE ON CAREER EDUCATION IN
THE NEW ECONOMY WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS TO SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ALSO HAVE PRESENTERS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FOR OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR.
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU WERE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS
THIS COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO.
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY.
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER. AND ACCESS CODE IS
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. PLEASE
DIAL. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
OR ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. WITH
THE ACCESS CODE NINE OR FIVE
NINE OR EIGHT NINE OR NINE OR
FOUR. THIS INFORMATION IS ALSO
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR OR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S EVENT WE WILL BE HEARING
ALL OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES
ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE'VE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK ONCE AGAIN YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
TELEPHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN THIS
REGARD. I WILL BE MAINTAINING
DECORUM DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR AVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUTED
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
IS CLOSE TO THE MATTER. AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE
ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE OF OUR
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES SO
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO THAT EVERYONE MAY BE
HEARD TODAY. TO OUR PANELISTS
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING VIA ZOOM
REMOTELY AND TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TUNING IN TANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS HOW WE MEASURE SUCCESS.
AND EVALUATE THE PERFORMANCE OF
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND HOW WE MAY
IMPROVE ON CURRENT EFFORTS SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE. THAT WORK
FORCE TRAINING DOLLARS ARE
GETTING PEOPLE INTO GOOD JOBS.
AND ON A PATH OF CAREER
ADVANCEMENT. THE TIMING FOR THIS
HEARING FRANKLY IS PRESCIENT THE
RECENT PANDEMIC HAS CREATED
UNPRECEDENTED CHANGES TO THE
WORK FORCE FROM EMPLOYEES EITHER
RETIRING EARLY. OR JUST LEAVING
THE WORK FORCE TO REMOTE WORK
LIFESTYLES. BUT THE FUTURE LOOKS
BRIGHT WITH THE OPPORTUNITY THE
PRESIDENT HAS JUST SIGNED THE
LARGEST INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT BILL IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY. ON THE
HEELS OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S ONE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
CALIFORNIA COMEBACK PLAN AS PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO STATE BUDGET.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT REQUIRED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
TRAINED AND CAPABLE OF DESIGNING
BUILDING AND MAINTAINING THE
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
ADDITIONALLY WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT OUR WORKFORCE AND CAREER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THIS STATE
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR EMPLOYERS. PROVIDING
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE SKILLS
NECESSARY. TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE. YET WITH ALL THIS
OPPORTUNITY INVESTMENT. AN
INVESTMENT THE NEWS ON THE
EMPLOYMENT FRONT IS MIXED. WHILE
THE STATE HAS ONE POINT ONE
MILLION JOB OPENINGS AS OF
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
THERE ARE OVER ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. UNEMPLOYED. ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THIS DISCONNECT.
FRANKLY MAY BE THAT THE JOBS
THAT THE UNEMPLOYED OR SEEKING
AND THE TRAINING REQUIRED FOR
SUCH POSITIONS DO NOT MATCH.
PERHAPS WE'RE SPENDING MONEY
TRAINING PEOPLE FOR JOBS THAT DO
NOT EXIST AT LEAST IN SOME
REGIONS OF THE STATE. I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION TO IDENTIFY WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN MEET THE NEEDS
OF EMPLOYERS WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING FLEXIBLE PATHWAYS INTO
GOOD JOBS. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY. EXCLUDED FROM THE
ECONOMIC SUCCESSES OF THE STATE.
WE ALL MUST COMMIT TO CREATE A
HIGHLY SKILLED HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE
WORKFORCE ENSURING THAT WE CAN
MEET THE DEMAND OF EMPLOYERS
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING QUALIFIED
EMPLOYEES WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
WORKERS WITH MARKETABLE SKILLS
THAT FACILITATE ACCESS TO GOOD
PAYING LIVING WAGE JOBS IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES. TO DO
THIS WE NEED TO ENSURE THE
POLICY MAKERS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MOST RELEVANT AND ACCURATE DATA.
TO ASSESS WHETHER CURRENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE MEETING
EMPLOYER DEMAND WHILE ALSO
GETTING JOB TRAINING PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS INTO THE JOBS FOR
WHICH THEY HAVE TRAINED.
CURRENTLY THE STATE DOES NOT
SYSTEMATICALLY MEASURE WHETHER
WORKERS ARE OBTAINING JOBS IN
THE OCCUPATIONS FOR WHICH THEY
HAVE TRAINED. AND JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS DON'T TRACK WORKERS
INTO THE LABOR MARKET FOR A
SUFFICIENT PERIOD FOLLOWING
PROGRAM PARTICIPATION TO
DETERMINE IF JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS ARE POSITIONING WORKERS
ON A PATH OF UPWARD MOBILITY. WE
NEED TO FIX THIS WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THE JOB TRAINING AND
EQUIVALENT JOB AVAILABLE THESE
LINES ACTUALLY CROSS. WE NEED TO
GIVE EMPLOYEES WHO WERE LOOKING
TO UPSKILL THE CONFIDENCE THAT
THE TRAINING THEY WILL RECEIVE.
WELL FOR THE MILITANT WAGE
COMPETITIVE ADVANCEMENT AND THE
ABILITY TO SEEK EMPLOYMENT IN
THEIR LOCAL AREA. I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM THE
PANELISTS IN THE PUBLIC TODAY.
AND ENGAGING IN ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS. ON HOW WE CAN BEST
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS VERY VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE. SO LET'S START
WITH OUR PANELISTS TODAY. AND
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF ONE
OF THE TIME OUR PANELISTS BUT
THE CURRENT PANEL THE FIRST
PANEL IS ON CURRENT PERFORMANCE
REPORTING DATA COLLECTION AND
EVALUATION METHODS OVERVIEW IN
OUR FIRST PANELIST MISTER TIM
RAINEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
SIR ABSOLUTELY MY PLEASURE THANK
YOU SENATOR ROSS- I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF- IT YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
WERE FOR TRAFFIC AND I WANTED TO
TRY TO- KIND OF BUILD ON ON WHAT
YOU SAID AND MAYBE EVEN PUT A
CHALLENGE OUT- I'M- GETTING DEEP
INTO THE DATA A CONVERSATION. IS
HANDLED BY THE SMART PEOPLE YOU
PUT ON THIS PANEL WITH ME
FRANKLY- I. VERY SMART PEOPLE ON
BOTH PANELS SAVE FOR ME- SAW IT
AGAIN I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF- BUT
THE REAL QUICKLY THE STATE
WORKFORCE BOARD IS PRIMARILY A
POLICY BODY- I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE WORK FORCE
WHAT WE ADVISE THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE. ALL THINGS WORK
FORCE DEVELOPMENT. WERE MADE UP
OF BUSINESS AND LABOR- AND STATE
AGENCIES THAT OVERSEE AND
ADMINISTER THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN FACT- CENTER
TYPE GYROS US ON THIS COMMITTEE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS ON THE STATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD-
WHAT SIZE I SHOULD PRIMARILY A
POLICY ENTITY HOWEVER. OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE TAKEN
ON MORE OF A PROGRAM ROLE-
INVESTING IN DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS THAT WOULD HELP INFORM
POLICY BUT ALSO DRIVE POLICY- SO
WE'VE WE'VE KIND OF DEVELOPED
THIS I THINK DO TANK- KIND OF
APPROACH. TO THE WORK WHERE
WE'RE INVESTING TO DRIVE A
SYSTEM CHANGE BUT WE'RE ALSO
LEARNING FROM THOSE INVESTMENTS.
IN WAYS THAT INFORM POLICY I'M-
SORRY I THE CHALLENGE. THAT I
WANTED TO PUT FORWARD REALLY.
QUICKLY IS. A MY- THE COME UP
FROM LOOKING AT THE PROGRAM DATA
AND THE WAY WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ANALYZE AND DO A
VALUATION WHAT. IS IT ISN'T THIS
THE SYSTEM ITSELF NEEDS TO BE RE
EVALUATED REEVALUATE- THE
TRADITIONAL APPROACH. TO FIX.
THAT FOCUSES ON INDIVIDUALS AND
THE HOPE THAT. PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS- ARE COMPETITIVE
ENOUGH TO LAND A JOB. THIS IS
THE KIND OF WAY THE TRADITIONAL
SYSTEM WORKS IT GIVES PEOPLE
WHAT WE THINK. WILL MAKE THEM
COMPETITIVE IN IN IN LABOR
MARKETS WE SORT OF PUSH THEM OUT
AND HOPE THEY LAND. A LOT OF
FOLKS CALL THAT TRAINING PRAY.
YOU MENTION THAT- GRACE THE
QUESTION ARE WE TRAINING PEOPLE
FOR JOBS THAT ACTUALLY EXIST.
ARE WE DOING RIGHT BY THESE
TRAINEES. AND I WOULD SAY IN THE
MICRO SENSE. IT DOES WORK TO
GIVE AN INDIVIDUAL A LEG UP IN
COMPETITIVE LABOR MARKETS IN THE
COMPETITION FOR A QUALITY JOB.
BUT IN THE MACRO SENSE IT IT IT
DOESN'T HOLD UP AS WELL- BECAUSE
WE'RE BUILDING COMPETITION FOR
TOO FEW GOOD JOBS AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY. WHEN WE DO THAT
THERE'S A DOWNWARD PRESSURE. OR
EFFECT ON WAGES. AND THEY WERE
VERY. VERY REAL HISTORICAL
IMPACTS OF PRIVILEGE AND RACE
AND GENDER ON WHO AND WHAT
GROUPS WENT OUT THAT SORT OF
COMPETITION. SO IN THIS WAY IF
OUR IF OUR END GAME IS EQUITY.
IT'S NOT SET UP FOR US TO REALLY
MOVE THE NEEDLE ON EQUITY ACROSS
THE ST REGIS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WHAT WE'RE
THINKING OF THE STATE WORKFORCE
BOARD IS REALLY TURNING THIS
TRADITIONAL APPROACH ON ITS
HEAD. SO IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING INDIVIDUAL SERVICES.
THE WORK FOR SYSTEM SHOULD ALSO
BE WORKING TO CREATE THE
CONDITIONS. TO PULL PEOPLE INTO
GOOD JOBS TO SUPPORT REGIONAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ESPECIALLY
AS YOU POINTED OUT WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE- TYPE TRAINING
SERVICES DIRECTLY TO THE
CREATION OF GOOD JOBS. AND THEN
FINALLY TO IMPROVE EXISTING
JOBS. WE HAVE A LOT OF EMPLOYERS
OUT. ASKING AND REACHING OUT
EVEN TO A WORKFORCE BOARDS AND
OTHER FOLKS- LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
ATTRACT RETAIN RETAIN OUT
WORKERS INJURED REDUCED
TURNOVER. SO IT'S A REALLY GREAT
TIME TO BE TALKING TO EMPLOYERS
BECAUSE OUR OPEN TO THIS ABOUT
JOB QUALITY HAD IMPROVED THAT TO
GET A TEASE. AT THESE
PRIORITIES- WE HAVE THIS THING
THAT WE'RE DRIVING AT THE STATE
WORKFORCE BILLBOARD CALLED THE
HIGH ROAD AGENDA. I DON'T
PRIORITIZE ECONOMIC EQUITY JOB
QUALITY AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE.
AND THAT APPROACH STARTS WITH
DEEP INDUSTRY ENGAGEMENT- AND.
THE RELATED WORK IS SYSTEM
ALIGNMENT. REGIONALLY IN. IN IN
A- STRENGTHENING THE ROLE OF.
THE BASE ORGANIZATIONS. TO
CONNECT MORE WORKERS FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THOSE.
BEEN LOCKED OUT OF PROSPERITY
FOR GENERATIONS. TO PATHWAYS TO
QUALITY JOBS- AND- THIS RAISES
A- QUESTION OR CHALLENGE WITH
DATA COLLECTION- BECAUSE- BY THE
WAY WE COLLECT PARTICIPANT DATA
OR PARTICIPANT DATA. DOESN'T GET
ANY OF THIS WORK- AND YOU GET
WHAT YOU MEASURE SO WHAT YOU
MEASURE- ACTUALLY DRIVES A LOT
OF THE ACTIVITIES IN THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE WORK FORCE
SYSTEM SO FOR NOT MEASURING AND
TRACKING. THESE MORE INTENSIVE
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES THAT
LOCAL BOARDS IN COLLEGES
ENGAGING REGIONALLY WITH
INDUSTRY AND LABOR- THEY WERE
NOT GOING TO GET THE ENERGY
PLACED IN IN THOSE AREAS- SO
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A REAL
CHALLENGE THAT I THINK DOESN'T
GET A DRESS WITH A PURCHASE
PARTICIPANT DATA. OUCH I THINK
I'LL STOP THERE I CENTERED
AROUND BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'VE GOT
A LOT OF FOLKS TOO. BUT YOU WANT
TO HEAR FROM AND ALL KIND OF
WAIT IN THE WINGS UNLESS YOU'VE
GOT. OTHER QUESTIONS FOR ME.
WELL LET ME JUST- MAYBE ASK A
QUESTION OR MAKE A COMMENT OR
MAYBE DO BOTH. YOU KNOW ONE OF
MY CONCERNS WAS THAT. WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE DETAILED INFORMATION
AS TO THE SPECIFIC TYPES OF JOBS
FOR WHICH THEY'RE OPENINGS AND
FOR WHICH EMPLOYERS. PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE NEED EMPLOYEES IN
PARTICULAR REGIONS. AND IF TRUE
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK IT'S
STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL.
CLASSIFICATIONS ARE SOME OF THE
OTHER REPORTS. PARTICULARLY DOWN
IN INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHERE I COME FROM AND THEY SAID
WELL WE NEED THREE THOUSAND.
WAREHOUSE WORKERS WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IS THAT A FORKLIFT OPERATOR
IS AT A COMPUTERIZED INVENTORY
CLERK. AND IT WOULD SEEM TO ME I
THINK IT'S TRUE THAT THE
TRAINING PROGRAM FOR EACH OF
THOSE WOULD VERY SIGNIFICANTLY
ONE FROM THE OTHER. SO IN ORDER
TO DESIGN THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
WHETHER YOU'RE IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BUSINESS OR- THE PRIVATE
SECTOR YOU NEED TO HAVE SOME.
GRANULARITY AS TO WHAT THE
NATURE OF THE SPECIFIC NATURE OF
THE JOB IS IN THE- SKILLS THAT
ARE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO MEET
THE NEED RIGHT. AND SO WHEN I
RISK FOLKS. IN GOVERNMENT IN
OUT- IF I NEEDED TO BE FILLED.
TWENTY FIVE- COMPUTERIZED
INVENTORY CLERKS POSITIONS THAT
I HAVE WHO WOULD I CALL. AND
WHERE WOULD I GO TO THE LODGE
THIS DATA AND IF I TURN TO THE
EDUCATORS AND I SAID WHERE WOULD
YOU GO TO FIND OUT IF SOMEONE
NEEDS COMPUTERIZED INVENTORY
CLERKS AND THE ANSWER IS WE
DON'T KNOW. OR THERE ISN'T
ANYBODY. AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY THE NATURE OF. PIECE OF
THE PROBLEM AND THE OTHER PIECE
OF THE PROBLEM IS THE DATA
COLLECTION SIMPLY FIGURING OUT
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY IS THAT SOMEBODY IS EARNED
WE NEED OCCUPATION WE NEED WAGE
RATE WE NEED JOB LOCATION SO WE
CAN SOMEHOW AND PERHAPS MORE. IN
AN ENHANCED. LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION SYSTEMS SO WE CAN
PUT THE PIECES TOGETHER AND SO
OUR EDUCATORS KNOW WHO TO TRAIN
AND WHAT TO TRAIN THE MEN DO YOU
AGREE WITH THAT RATHER LONG
COMMENT THAT DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
A QUESTION MARK AT THE END. I
THINK IT WAS A TERRIFIC COMIC
NIGHT AND I AGREE COMPLETELY I
DO TOO TWO ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS
SO THAT IS. WHAT WE COULD USE
MORE CORRECT GRANULAR- THAT DATA
ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN REGIONAL
LABOR MARKETS OUT AND I THINK
THAT MY COLLEAGUES ON THE ON
THE- THE OTHER PANEL- COULD
COULD ADDRESS THAT. THE WAY
WE'VE BEEN GETTING AT IT IS THIS
BUILDING THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
INDUSTRY ON THE GRASS RIGHT THAT
USING THE DATA THE LABOR MARKET
DATA TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
TRENDS ARE. I WANT A LONG TERM
PROJECTIONS ARE SO WE UNDERSTAND
WHICH INDUSTRY SECTORS ARE
REALLY DRIVING EMPLOYMENT- BUT
THEN NOT RELYING ON THE DATA
MUCH PAST THAT POINT- INSTEAD
ENGAGING EMPLOYERS IN THE SECTOR
SO THEY WERE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS. AND COKE PLANNING
WITH THEM ON WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE GOING TO BE OVER THE NEXT
TWO TO FIVE YEARS. AND IN
RESPONDING TO THIS NEED SO
THERE'S I THINK WE WANT WHENEVER
WE COULD HAVE BETTER DATA BUT
WE'RE NEVER GONNA GET AWAY FROM
THE VALUE. OF THAT DIRECT
CONNECTION WITH INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THAT REAL TIME DATA IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE- WHAT WE NEED TO
MAKE A WORK FOR SYSTEM WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE EMPLOYER AND JOB
SEEKER. AND I THINK ON THE ON
THE PERFORMANCE SIDE IN TERMS
OF. OUTCOMES I AGREE WITH YOU
THERE TOO I THINK WE NEED MORE
GRANULAR DATA THE WAY WE.
COLLECTED WE FIRST USED. YOU
SCALIGER- TO COLLECT PARTICIPANT
DATA- AND THAT GIVES US- SOME OF
WHAT WE NOT NOT NOT ALL. THEN WE
RELY ON. SUPPLEMENTAL QUARTERLY
REPORTS FROM OUR PROJECTS IN
FROM EMPLOYERS- TO TELL US
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND TO GET US. A CLEAR SENSE
OF WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S NOT
WORKING SO WE CAN MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS ON THE ALONG THE
WAY. AND THEN WE DO THIRD PARTY
EVALUATIONS OF OUR PROBLEM OUR
PROJECT WORK. BUT THAT THOSE
LAST TWO- WAYS OF GETTING AT IT.
THE CALL COLLECTING A
SUPPLEMENTAL QUARTERLY REPORTS
PUTS AN ONUS ON EMPLOYERS AND
THE PROJECTS. TO BE COSTLY
PROVIDING US NARRATIVE REPORTS
WHICH IS TIME CONSUMING- AND
THEN THE THIRD PARTY EVALUATION
WORK IS. YOU KNOW IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT CHEAP EVEN THOUGH WE WORK
WITH THE UC SYSTEM- WHICH GIVES
US A GREAT VALUE- AND SOME OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS DID YOU REALLY
TERRIFIC WORK. IT IT IT IS. WHAT
WE USED TO GET WHAT WE NEED AND
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE- ASKING OF
THE OTHER PANELISTS JUST GIVE
YOU SOME IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN.
AUTOMATE THAT. RIGHT AND GIVEN
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT FLOWS
THROUGH THE DREADED JOB TRAINING
PIPELINE AND I THINK YOU WOULD.
AGREE THAT IS NOT INSUBSTANTIAL-
IN FACT IT'S FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT
AS IT SHOULD BE. EVEN MORE SO
NOW DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND AS
WE MOVE HOPEFULLY INTO THE POST
PANDEMIC ERA. ARE YOU ABLE IS
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
STRUCTURE AND SYSTEM. ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHAT PERCENTAGE. OF
PEOPLE WHO PASSED THROUGH OUR
TRAINING PIPELINE. ACTUALLY
SECURE A JOB IN THE FIELD FOR
WHICH THEY RECEIVE TRAINING. NOT
NOT AUTOMATICALLY THE WAY THAT
WE GET IT THAT IS TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTS- THAT COME
FROM OUR OUR PROJECTS WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME- COMMUNICATING WITH
PROJECTS DOING COMMUNITIES OF
PRACTICE AND THAT SORT OF THING
VERY HANDS ON- BUT NO THERE'S NO
I KNOW WHATYOU'RE ASKING AND I
DON'T THERE'S NO AUTOMATED WAY
TO GET THAT DATA- DO WE DON'T WE
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S 50% I'M
NOT BEING CRITICAL I'M JUST.
TRYING TO BRING THE PROBLEM. WE
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S 50% OF
THOSE WHO WERE TRAINED AT SECURE
EMPLOYMENT IN THE FIELDS WHICH
ARE TRAINED OR WHETHER IT'S 70%
OR- EIGHTY WITH ANY DEGREE OF
CERTAINTY I GUESS THAT WE COULD
TAKE. TO THE BANK SO TO SPEAK.
WE CAN TELL YOU THAT- WE CAN
TELL YOU- BY LOOKING AT THE DATA
COMES FROM CAL JOBS AND
COMPARING IT AGAINST THE BASE
WAGE FILE- AND WE CAN LOOK AT-
PRE. PRE PLACEMENT DATA. PRE
PROGRAMMED DATA RATHER AND THEN
POST OP PROGRAM DATA AND WE CAN
LOOK AT QUARTERS OUT- AND TELL
YOU- WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
TRAINEES. ACTUALLY GOT
EMPLOYMENT WE CAN TELL YOU THEIR
WAGES- BUT WE CAN'T TELL YOU IS
WHAT SPECIFICALLY- THAT JOB IS
OR WHAT THAT OCCUPATION IS- AND
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THAT MAYBE THAT THE- OTHER FOLKS
ON THE CALL CAN ADDRESS. BUT THE
OTHER THING WE CAN TELL YOU IS
THAT- THE BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS
THAT TRAINING. IS IT COMPARED TO
OTHER KINDS OF INTERVENTIONS OR
SERVICES TRAINING AT. GET YOU. A
LOT GREATER OUTCOME IN TERMS OF
JOB PLACEMENT AND QUALITY JOB
PLACEMENT THEN YOU THEN YOU.
OTHERWISE WOULD WITHOUT
TRAINING. AND I THINK IT'S- IT
MAY BE TALKING TO ADDRESS THIS
R. CAL SKILLS WORK. THAT WAS
ANALYZED BY DO YOU SEE POLICY
LAB FOUND THAT. AS MUCH AS OTHER
30% GAIN IN TERMS OF WAGES FOR
PEOPLE WENT TO TRAINING AS
OPPOSED TO PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T.
BOB I THINK THAT TRAINING WAS
ALWAYS WRAPPED WITH OTHER KINDS
OF SERVICES. I'M SURE I'M JUST
CONCERNED. FOR EXAMPLE WE DON'T
KNOW. IF THE DENTAL HYGIENIST
WHO WENT THROUGH. ONE OF OUR JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS. IN AN AREA
THAT HAPPENS TO HAVE A LOT OF
DENTAL HYGIENISTS. WOUND UP AT
STARBUCKS. WITH THE WAGES
THEY'RE NOW PAYING IN THE
BENEFITS WE CAN'T REALLY TELL
WHETHER THERE'S ANY REASONABLE
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE TRAINING
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL RECEIVED AND
THE JOB SKILLS THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PERFORMING ALL WE KNOW
IS THAT THE PAY OR THE PAY RATE
SEEMS TO BE ABOUT RIGHT FOR THE
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT THEY WENT
THROUGH THAT. FIRST STATEMENT
YEAH THAT'S THAT THEY'RE NOT-
AND I EXPECT THINK THAT I MEAN
THERE IS THERE IS SOME LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE WE GAIN FROM THE DATA
ON WHAT SECTORS- PEOPLE WENT TO
WORK AND- BUT I THINK YOU IT
DOESN'T GET TO THE LEVEL OF
GRANULARITY THAT THAT THAT THAT
I THINK THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
THAT YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT. WELL
I'VE LISTENED I DON'T WANT
ANYBODYSUGGEST TO YOU ANYTHING
TO THE CONTRARY I COMPLETELY. IN
AWE OF WHAT YOU WILL DO AND THE
HARD WORK THAT YOU IN THE
REGIONAL BOARDS AROUND THE STATE
INCLUDING MANY OF MY FRIENDS WHO
SIT ON THEM- PERFORM EACH AND
EVERY DAY OF THE YEAR FOR ALL
THE REST OF US TRYING TO KEEP
PEOPLE EMPLOYED AND GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK YOU NEED TO BE BACK
TO WORK SO THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR. OKAY OUR NEXT
PANELIST IS- NICOLE LIKE TURKISH
DEPUTY CHIEF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND PROGRAM
ACCOUNTABILITY SECTION WORK FOR
SERVICES BRANCH EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT THAT'S A
MOUTHFUL. WELCOME THANK YOU
SENATOR YES THAT IS A MOUSE ALL.
SO IN REGARDS TO- HOW WE REPORT
OUR PERFORMANCE FILL OUR WORKER
SERVICES BRANCH WITHIN EDG WILL
OVERSEE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS MOSTLY UNDER
THE WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY AFTER WE GO UP- WE
CAPTURE REPORT AND MEASURE OUR
PROGRAM PERFORMANCE BASED ON THE
U. S. DEPARTMENT OF LABOR'S
REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS THERE IS A FINE-
IMMERSIVE PROGRAM PRESENTS ARE
FIVE- PERFORMANCE MEASURES ABOUT
ALL ARE WHAT WE ARE CONTINUALLY
REPORTING AND BEING MEASURED
AGAINST. THE FIRST ONE IS
EMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE SECOND
QUARTER AFTER EXIT SO IT'S
LOOKING OUT OF THOSE THAT FINISH
OUR PROGRAM HOW MANY OF THEM ARE
EMPLOYED IN THE SECOND QUARTER
AFTER THE ACCIDENT FROM A
PROGRAM WE ALSO LOOK AT
EMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER AFTER EXIT WHICH AGAIN
AFTER THEY FINISH OUR- PROGRAM
ARE THEY EMPLOYED IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER AFTER THEY'VE EXITED
THAT PROGRAM. WE ALSO LOOK AT
MEDIAN EARNINGS IN THE SECOND
QUARTER AFTER EXIT SO ALL OF
THOSE THAT FINISHED HER PROGRAM
WHAT IS THE MEDIAN EARNING OF
THOSE THAT DID HAVE A JOB IN THE
SECOND QUARTER- AND THEN WE ALSO
FOR THOSE THAT ARE IN TRAINING
OR EDUCATION WE LOOK AT
CREDENTIAL ATTAINMENT SO THOSE
THAT RESPOND TO TRAINING HOME
YOU'RE ACTUALLY OBTAINING A
CREDENTIAL AND THEN WE ALSO LOOK
AT MEASURABLE SKILL GAMES WHICH
IS REALLY JUST MEASURING IF YOUR
EDUCATION OR TRAINING ARE YOU
MAKING THAT DOCUMENTED PROGRESS.
TOWARDS GAINING SKILLS TECHNICAL
SKILLS OCCUPATIONAL SKILLS.
NEEDED- FOR THE OCCUPATION. SO
WE NEGOTIATE FOR FIVE MEASURES
FOR THE TO THE PARTICIPANTS
BEING TO GO. WHAT THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. AND IS LIVE
ANIMAL- PERFORMANCE GOALS EXCUSE
ME FOR EACH OF THOSE DIFFERENT
MEASURES. THAT INDICATE WHAT
KIND OF OUR EXPECTATION AS WE
ARE PROGRAMMED FOR HER SISTER
I'M SO IT'S NOT WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT A 100% EMPLOYMENT-
BECAUSE WE REALLY ARE SERVING
THOSE. ARE THE HARD TO HAVE THE
OST OF. YOURS THINGS LIKE THAT
AND STILL ARE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES ARE BASED ON WHO WERE
ACTUALLY SERVING THAT
DEMOGRAPHIC. AS WELL AS THE-
LOCAL ECONOMIES THE STATE
ECONOMY DEAL LOOKS AT THAT AND
DETERMINE TO WHAT OUR
EXPECTATIONS SHOULD BE. OVER
EACH OF OUR PROGRAMS AND FOR
EACH OF THOSE FIVE MEASURES WE
CAN'T NEGOTIATE WHAT OUR RATES
SHOULD BE. AND WE ROUTINELY MEET
OR EXCEED AT THOSE RATES ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS- WE REPORT THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ARE FINAL
AND ANNUAL REPORTS AND THEN
WE'LL EVALUATE ARE WE ACTUALLY
NEEDING- OR EXCEEDED OUR
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS- AND WE
GENERALLY ARE. FOR KNOX AND THEN
WE THAT'S WHERE WE KIND OF
INTERVENE AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ANY OF. OUR LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AREAS. IN
REGARDS TO INCOME MOBILITY- AND
WHETHER TO PRO BUT ARE GETTING
JOB AND ALL. VIRTUALLY TRAIN
FOR- OUR INCOME MOBILITY IT
REALLY WE CAN LOOK AT THE MEDIAN
EARNINGS. TO SENIOR IF THERE
ISN'T AN EARNINGSINCREASE FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS- THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
SPECIFICALLY- WERE SPECIFICALLY
MEASURED OPTION BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN LOOK INTO.
A TRAINING PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
GETTING JOBS IN OCCUPATIONS THAT
THEY TRAIN FOR THE TEN MENTIONED
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT ALREADY- WE
DO NOT AUTOMATICALLY GET
INFORMATION- ON OCCUPATIONAL
CODES HOWEVER- STUFF CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH OUR WORKFORCE FOUND
LOCAL WORKER LOCAL WORK FORCE
KNOWN AREA STAFF. CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH THE INDIVIDUALS AND ENTER
THAT DATA INTO OUR SYSTEM SO
THEY CANNOT- TALK TO THEM FIND
OUT WHERE THEY'RE EMPLOYED AT
WHAT OCCUPATION IS. AND THEY
ENTER IT INTO OUR CULTURAL.
SYSTEM WHERE WE HAVE ACCESS TO
IT. I'M SO WE DO THAT YOU CAN
ALSO KIND OF A LOW TO THAT WE DO
GET INFORMATION ON THE FACTORS
SO WE ALSO WILL NO INDUSTRY. WE
KNOW THAT LIMITED YOU CAN'T
ALWAYS DRAW CONCLUSIONS BASED ON
INDUSTRY- BUT WE DO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AUTOMATICALLY
AVAILABLE AS WELL. SH IN REGARDS
TO ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
BEING PLACED INTO JOBS THAT
PROVIDE GOOD BEIJING. THE
MAJORITY OF THE TRAINING FUNDS
THAT WE UTILIZE FOR OUR PROGRAMS
THE REQUIRED TO USE SOMETHING
THAT'S CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
ELIGIBLE TRAINING PROVIDER LIST
WHICH IS A DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
REQUIRED- LIST UNDER THE WE OWE
OUR REGULATIONS AND THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT CRITERIA AND
RULES AROUND WHAT A TRAINING
PROVIDER NEEDS TO DO TO BE ABLE
TO BE ON THAT LIST. SO THAT
HOPEFULLY THAT IS BLESSED- BUT
WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE MEETING ALL
THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
TRAINING PROVIDERS AND PROGRAMS
ON THAT LIST AND WE'VE ADDED
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS TO
ENSURE ABOUT THE PROVIDERS ON
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE ON THAT
LIST REALLY ARE QUALITY AND SO
THE WAY THAT WE DO THAT IS NOT
WE EXPECT PERFORMANCE
EXPECTATIONS FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND IF THEY FALL BELOW THOSE
EXPECTATIONS AND THEY NO LONGER
ARE ALLOWED TO BE ON THE LIST-
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
PROGRAMS ARE IN IN DEMAND
INDUSTRIES IN THE STATE OR THE
LOCAL AREA WHERE IT'S BEING
OFFERED TO ENSURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE GOING INTO
THOSE PROGRAMS IN THOSE TRAINING
RUNS THAT WE'RE INVESTING. ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT AND DEMAND
INDUSTRIES AND ARE WITH PROGRAMS
I HAVE A RECORD. OF THAT
PERFORMANCE. SH AND THEN IT
REGARDS TO THE I THINK IS THE
OUR PROGRAM I THINK. WE ARE
ROUTINELY MEET OR EXCEED OUR
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS THAT
ARE SET UP BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR- AND AS I MENTIONED IF WE-
IDENTIFY ANY AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT THAT WE ALWAYS WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AREAS- OUR OTHER
PROGRAM AREAS TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE ARE. ON MEDICAID. IN
REGARDS TO. PERFORMANCE AND
EVALUATION INFORMATION AND HOW
IT'S REPORTED TO THE PUBLIC. SO
OUR PERFORMANCE INFORMATION FOR
OUR WORKFORCE SERVICES BRANCH
ADMINISTER PROGRAMS ARE MADE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND BE AT
WORK FORCE ANIMATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT NARRATIVE REPORT.
OR IS POSTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
WEBSITE ANNUALLY USUALLY AND
DECEMBER- THE WSB ALSO PROVIDES
PROGRAM DENIED TO THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
CREATE THE WORK FORCE METRICS
DASHBOARD REPORT THAT'S REQUIRED
UNDER EIGHTY TWENTY ONE FORTY
EIGHT- IN ADDITION DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR ALSO TAKES ALL THE DATA
THAT WE SUBMIT TO THEM. AND THEY
MAKE IT PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON
THEIR WEBSITE AS WELL- AND YOU
CAN DOWNLOAD IT THE BILLABLE FOR
PUBLIC IF. WE UTILIZE PAST
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES AS ONE OF
OUR DECIDING FACTORS WHEN MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT
ORGANIZATIONS OR DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS STILL. JUST KIND OF-
TRYING TO GET INTO HOW WE USE
THEM OVER PERFORMANCE
INFORMATION- AND WE ALSO LOOK AT
PAST PERFORMANCE TO DRIVE POLICY
DECISIONS- AND WHICH POPULATIONS
TO CIRCLE SOME OF OUR
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS AS WELL. AND
THEN I THAT'S IT FOR MY PORTION-
AND THEN FOR THE BASE WAGE AND I
WAS GOING TO KICK IT OVER TO
PAMELA. BUT SENATOR I DON'T SEE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR ME BEFORE THAT
OR YOU WANT TO PAMELA JUST. LET
ME TRY TO PHRASE QUESTIONS I'VE
BEEN SUCH A LONG TIME SINCE I'VE
BEEN A LAWYER I DO'T KNOW THAT
I KNOW WHAT I ASK ON ANYMORE BUT-
I'M- IN GOOD COMPANY I'M IN
SACRAMENTO- DO WE KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN YOU HAVE GRADUATES
FROM. INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
COMPLETED TRAINING PROGRAMS. AND
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA THAT YOU
CURRENTLY COMPILE. CAN YOU LOOK
IT BUT SAY WAGE INCREASE BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED YOU CAN EARNINGS
INCREASE YOU CAN MEASURE THAT DO
WE KNOW WHETHER THIS EARNINGS
INCREASE IS THE RESULT OF A NEW
JOB IN A FIELD FOR WHICH THE
EMPLOYEE RECEIVED TRAINING OR
WHETHER IT'S IN A- THE EMPLOYEE
SIMPLY STAYED IN THE GENERAL.
FIELD OF WORK AND RECEIVE
PROMOTIONS. SO WE- WE WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY KNOW- WE DON'T BUT
LIKE I SAID WE ONLY TRACK
OCCUPATION CODE WHEN. STOCK FOR
ABLE TO GET THAT INFORMATION
FROM THE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS SO
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE IT AND
THOSE INSTANCES OF BUT IF WE
DON'T IT WOULD REALLY BE LOOKING
AT INDUSTRIES THING IF THERE
ISN'T AN INDUSTRY CHANGE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL- BEFORE AND AFTER THE
PROGRAM- BUT IT ALL KIND OF
DEPENDS CASE BY CASE AND IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
BLANKET ACROSS THE BOARD SAY YES
WE CAN DO THAT TOO. WELL ABOVE
THE I KEEP USING WAREHOUSES BUT
REMEMBER I LIVE IN YOUR HOUSE
CENTRAL DONE IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT SO I'M IN THE
WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY AND I'VE BEEN
A FORKLIFT OPERATOR AND- I HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROMOTE INTO
OF. FORKLIFT LEAD POSITION BUT I
GO I SEE AN AD IN THE NEWSPAPER
EITHER MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR A
PRIVATE SECTR TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND I GO INTO TRAINING TO BE- I
GUESS IF THIS IS THE JOB OF
COMPUTERIZED INVENTORY CONTROL
CLERK. SOUNDS GOOD RIGHT. AND I
COMPLETE THIS TWELVE MONTH
TRAINING PROGRAM AND COME OUT
WITH THE CERTIFICATE. IT'S NOT A
NECESSARILY A DEGREE PROGRAM BUT
A CERTIFICATE FOR RATHER
DETAILED. YOU KNOW A LOT OF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY STUFF
THAT OLD PEOPLE LIKE ME HAVE
TROUBLE WITH BUT I DO IT ANYWAY.
BUT I COME OUT I DON'T GET A I
CAN'T FIND A JOB AND I STAY IN
THE WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY AND GET
MY FORKLIFT PROMOTION TO LEAD.
YOUR RECORDS ARE GOING TO SHOW.
AN OVERALL EARNINGS INCREASE.
ALBEIT IN THE SAME INDUSTRY.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO TELL
WHETHER OR NOT I GOT MY JOB. AS
A COMPUTERIZED INVENTORY CONTROL
CLERK RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT. FOR
ME ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT KEPT
THE CROPS UP THEN IS HOW WE
EVALUATE OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS
SO. ARE THERE ANY CONSEQUENCES
FOR TRAINING PROGRAMS IT WAS
RECEIVED THE FUNDS. OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FUNDS YOU
KNOW THE PASS I THINK LARGELY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALTHOUGH I THINK TIME AND TIME
IN THE STATE WE- KICK IN MONEY.
ARE THERE ANY CONSEQUENCES FOR
THESE PROGRAMS THAT. DON'T HAVE
A VERY HIGH. A PERCENTAGE OF
PLACING PEOPLE IN JOBS FOR WHICH
THEY- RECEIVE MONEY AND PROVIDED
TRAINING. YEAH I STILL FOR OUR
PROGRAMS AS I MENTIONED WE THE
MAJORITY OF OUR FUNDS- YOU'RE
REQUIRED TO USE A PROVIDER
THAT'S LISTED ON THE OLD WILL
TRAINING PROVIDER LIST- AND PART
OF BEING ON THAT LIST IS
ANNUALLY WE EVALUATE WHAT.
PERFORMANCE LOOKS LIKE FOR THAT
PROGRAM- AND IF THE PERFORMANCE
FALLS BELOW OUR EXPECTATIONS
THEN WE ALL WILL REMOVE THAT
PROVIDER FROM THE LIST OR NOT
PROGRAM FROM THE LIST I SHOULD
SAY- AND THEN GIVE THE LOCAL
AREAS CAN'T USE THAT PROGRAM
ANYMORE SO THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE RECEIVING- ARE
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR TRAINING. BUT
YOU'RE LIMITED TO THE DATA THAT
YOU HAVE AGAINST. WHICH TO
MEASURE PERFORMANCE RIGHT. YES
THAT'S CORRECT SO YOU WOULDN'T
SO I GUESS THE ANSWER TO MY
QUESTION ON IN TERMS OF
CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT DO NOT. INSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO COMPLETE
THE TRAINING GET JOBS IN THE
FIELD FOR WHICH ARE TRAINED.
THERE'S NO MEANS TO EVALUATE
THOSE TRAINING PROVIDERS CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT SO WE ARE ONLY
MEASURING THE TRAINING PROVIDERS
ON AT THE SAME- YEAH THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER SO EMPLOYMENT
RATES THE MEDIAN WAGES
CREDENTIAL TEAM MATT AND
MEASURABLE SKILL GAMES SO WE'RE
NOT LOOKING AT. TRAINING RELATED
EMPLOYMENT OR NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
RECEIVED A JOB- AND- OKAY. CAN
YOU MENTIONED TRYING TO TRUCK IN
DEMAND INDUSTRIES IN A STATE OR
LOCAL AREA BUT YOU KNOW MY
CONCERN IS REGIONAL LIES TO THE
DATA SO THAT BECAUSE MOST
TRAINING PROGRAMS A REGIONAL AND
BY LESS PEOPLE OR MOBILE THEY
GENERALLY- VERTICALLY THOSE-
RETRAINING I WANT A JOB IN THE
AREA WHERE THEY LIVE AND THEY'VE
WORKED AND WHERE THEIR FAMILY IS
IN OUR DATA DOESN'T REALLY ALLOW
US TO DRILL DOWN AND- I GATHER
AND OBTAIN REGIONALIZED- JOB.
AVAILABILITY DATA. IT IS AM I
RIGHT. I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD
BE THE APPROPRIATE PERSON TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION- WE DO HAVE
STATISTICS BASED ON WHAT'S IN
OUR CULTURAL SYSTEM ON JOB
OPENINGS THAT ARE RECORDED WE DO
ALSO RECEIVE INFORMATION FROM
OUR LABOR MARKET- TEAM UP ON
WHAT'S AVAILABLE AND YOU CAN
DRILL DOWN- FUEL THE-
METROPOLITAN STATISTICAL AREA.
I'M SO YOU CAN GET MORE
REGIONALLY SPECIFIC BUT IN
REGARDS TO OUR ELIGIBLE TRAINING
PROVIDER LIST THAT I MENTIONED
IN THE IN DEMAND INDUSTRIES WE
REALLY RELY ON OUR LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AREAS.
HE'LL BE AWARE OF THAT- AS OUR
NOMINATING THE PROGRAMS RIGHT
WELL LET ME ASK ONE FINAL
QUESTION AND AGAIN- LET ME JUST
SAY HOW- HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU AND ALL OF THE FOLKS AT
THE E. D. I HAVE DONE AND
CONTINUE TO DO I'M NOT ONE TO.
BE ADMINISTERING A SPANKING I
THINK YOU ALL WORKED VERY VERY
HARD UNDER VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING YOU DO AND INCLUDING
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE TAKING TIME
AWAY FROM THAT WORKLOAD TO. COME
TALK TO ME TODAY SO THANK YOU
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT- I'M
INTERESTED IN EXPLORING AT SOME
POINT. IS ENHANCING OUR LABOR
MARKET INFORMATION SYSTEM DATA.
TO INCLUDE SOME OF THE DATA
ITEMS THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO
YOU- AND FRANKLY HANDY KIP YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES TO DDD AND
GIVING US THE INFORMATION AND
PROVIDING THE GUIDANCE I THINK
TO TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE. AND THAT THOSE
DATA ITEMS INCLUDE. OCCUPATION-
A JOB SITE WAGE RATE TIED TO THE
PARTICULAR OCCUPATION PARTICULAR
JOB THAT THE INDIVIDUAL IS
PERFORMING. HOW INVOLVED WITH
AND I REALIZE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
GOING THROUGH SOME OTHER
MODIFICATIONS TO YOUR DATA
SYSTEMS. AND HAVING SPENT SIX
YEARS ON BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
STATE ADMINISTRATION LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I'VE SEEN EVERY I. T.
PROJECT KNOWN TO MAN SO I KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT THEY ARE. BUT HOW
DIFFICULT WOULD IT BE TO ADD. A
FEW DATA LINES TO. YOUR SYSTEM
AS IT IS BEING MODIFIED FOR
OTHER REASONS SH SO I ACTUALLY
AM GOING TO DEFERRED DOT
QUESTION TO PAMELA BECAUSE I
THINK SHE'S GOING TO COVER THAT
AND- SECTION PERFECT WE'VE BEEN
GREAT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AND
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DO. THANK
YOU SENATOR. OUR NEXT PANELIST
IS SET UP. CAMP KUTTNER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TAX BRANCH EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. THANK YOU
FOR INVITING US TODAY- TO
NICOLE'S QUESTION AND IT'S A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER DOWN IN THE
PRESENTATION- BUT- IT. THE BASE
WAGE FILE IS A DATA BASE
REPOSITORY FOR INFORMATION SO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING A
DATABASE- SO REALLY LOOKING AT
EXPANDING THE DATABASE IS BASED
ON WHAT DATA ELEMENTS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE- US TO CAPTURE. AND
THE EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO- BRING
THAT INFORMATION FORWARD TO US
AND HAVING THE FUNDING
MECHANISMS IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT
CHANGE SO IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTION THAT WOULD. THAT
WOULD BE MY ANSWER SO WHAT WE
WOULD NEED TO HAVE I THINK BUT
YOU'RE PROBABLY MORE EXPERT THIS
THAN I BUT IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
IF WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
IS WHAT THE JOB NEEDS OUR ACTUAL
JOB NEEDS ARE IN A PARTICULAR
REGION AND WHETHER INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE TRAINING AND RECEIVED A
JOB IN THE FIELD FOR WHICH THEY
ARE TRAINED. WE WOULD NEED TO
HAVE A SPECIFIC OCCUPATIONAL.
DATE OF. N. N. A WAGE RATE WITH
ME AT A JOB. HAVE TO DEFERRED IN
THE CALL OR LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION DIVISION FROM THAT
BUT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS CURRENTLY THE
BASE WAGE FILE INFORMATION
THAT'S REPORTED TO US INCLUDES
THE EMPLOYEES SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER THEIR NAME WHICH IS FIRST
MIDDLE INITIAL AND LAST THE
TOTAL SUBJECT WAGES. WAGES IN
THE PET WITHHELD SO THAT'S
CURRENTLY WHAT EMPLOYERS ARE
REPORTING TO US RIGHT NOW WE
COLLECT THAT FROM THE- EMPLOYERS
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
PROGRAMS AND BASICALLY IT'S A
DATABASE REPOSITORY WHERE THE
WAGES THAT INFORMATION IS
MAINTAINED AND TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA OF THE QUANTITY OF THE DATA
THAT WE RECEIVE IN THIS AREA WE
HAVE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
EMPLOYERS AND THEY REPORT AN
AVERAGE OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION
WAGE LINES EACH QUARTER. BUT IT
IS IT MOSTLY ELECTRONIC
REPORTING. I NINE POINT 9% IS
ELECTRONIC REPORTING WHICH WOULD
WHICH IS WHICH SHOULD EASE THE
WORKLOAD A LITTLE BIT FOR.
EVERYONE I WOULD THINK- WE'VE
BEEN PHENOMENALLY SUCCESSFUL AND
HAVING- ELECTRONIC REPORTING
SYSTEM WE HAVE MULTIPLE CHANNELS
AVAILABLE TO THE EMPLOYER TO
REPORT TO US- VIA- AN ONLINE
SYSTEM WE ALSO DO BULK FILE
TRANSFERS AND- WE HAVE A VERY
SMALL PAPER PROCESSING- FOR TAX
INFORMATION- I'M STILL ON GOING.
ON ONE OF MY THOUGHTS IS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE PROCESS
THROUGH THE PIPELINE FOR.
TRAINING JOB TRAINING AND JOB
RETRAINING- IS SIGNIFICANT AND I
DON'T KNOW I MEAN IT'S CERTAINLY
IN THE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT MAY BE MUCH MORE THAN
THAT YOU ALL WOULD KNOW THAT.
AND THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FOLKS WOULD KNOW THAT. BUT THE
SAVINGS IN CUTTING OUT THE
WASTED TRAINING TO MAKE SURE THE
TRAINING IS ACTUALLY DELIVERED
TO PEOPLE WHO NEED TRAINING FOR
JOBS THAT ACTUALLY EXIST. MY
UNINFORMED GREATLY UNINFORMED
BRAIN TELLS ME WOULD PROBABLY
PAY. CERTAINLY OVER THE LONG RUN
FOR ANY MODIFICATIONS THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE TO THE DATA SYSTEM
IN ORDER TO COLLECT THE DATA. TO
DETERMINE JOB NEEDS AND JOB
MATCH YES IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT I
DON'T I DON'T I'M NOT ASKING YOU
TO. YOU KNOW. THIS IS NOT GONNA
GOTCHA BUT I DID JUST MY THOUGHT
THAT THERE MIGHT BE IF WE CAN'T
TELL WHETHER THE TRAINING THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING TO EMPLOYEES
RESULTS IN A JOB IN THAT FIELD
FOR WHICH WE ARE PROVIDING THE
TRAINING AN EMPLOYEE HAS TO GO
DO SOMETHING ELSE THEN THERE
SHOULD BE A VALUE ATTACHED TO
THAT THAT COULD BE SAVED IF WE
COULD ACTUALLY MAKE THE LINES
CONNECT. AND I WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT. I DON'T- I DON'T
THINK I HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS MAN DO I MISS
ANYTHING. DO YOU WANT ME TO GO
THROUGH THE REST OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU SUBMITTED
ABOUT WHAT WE FOUND IN OUR
RESEARCH FOR OTHER STATES YES
MA'AM THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL- YOU
DID ASK- US TO COMPARE BASE
WHICH DATABASE TO WHAT WAS DONE
IN OTHER STATES. WE'RE NOT
EXPERTS IN WHAT THE OTHER STATES
TOO SO WE WENT OUT AND DID A
LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH- WE
LOOKED AT THE THREE LARGEST
STATES- WHICH CALIFORNIA IS BY
FAR THE LARGEST BUT WE ALSO-
LOOKED AT NEW YORK FLORIDA AND
TEXAS AND THEN WE LOOK AT THE
STREET THREE STATES THAT ARE
CLOSEST TO CALIFORNIA OREGON
NEVADA AND ARIZONA. AND WE FOUND
THAT- FOR THE MOST PART THE DATA
COLLECTED BY THESE STATES IS THE
SAME AS THE DATA ELEMENTS EDT
COLLECTS WITH ONE EXCEPTION-
WHICH WAS OREGON AND THEY
COLLECT THE NUMBER OF HOURS
WORKED FOR EACH EMPLOYEE. THEN
WE WENT OUT- AND LOOKED AT A
VARIETY OF OTHER STATES- WHAT
DATA THEY WERE COLLECTING. AND
SOME OF THE STATES THAT WE
LOOKED AT WERE ALASKA INDIANA
IOWA REALLY STATES THAT HAD-
QUITE A BIT OF PUBLIC
INFORMATION OUT THERE AND BASED
ON OUR LIMITED RESEARCH THERE
WAS QUITE A BIT OF VARIANCE
BETWEEN THE DATA ELEMENTS OF THE
OTHER STATES COLLECTED. RANGING
FROM HOURS AND WEEKS WORK TO THE
STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL CODE AND
WHETHER AND THERE'S ALSO A
VARIANCE AND WHETHER THE DATA IS
MANDATORY OR VOLUNTARY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO REPORT IT. SO WE
FOUND FIVE STATES THE COLLECTED
HOURS WORKED FOR HAD WEEKS WORK-
THREE STATES DID ASK FOR THE
STANDARD OCCUPATIONAL CODE ENTRY
STATES WANTED WORK LOCATION- BUT
INTO THE STATES IT WAS VOLUNTARY
AS OPPOSED TO- MANDATORY. DATA
COLLECTION- THERE WAS ALSO QUITE
AROUND- WHAT IT JUST ALL TYPES
OF DATA INCLUDING DATA ON
EMPLOYEE OCCUPATION COULD BE
COLLECTED THROUGH THE BASE WHICH
FILE AND I THINK I DRESS THAT
EARLIER BUT THE DATA THAT COULD
BE COLLECTED THROUGH THE BASE
WAGE FILE WOULD BE DEPENDENT ON
LEGISLATION AND WHAT WAS
MANDATED TO BE REPORTED BY THE
EMPLOYERS- EDIE'S CAPACITY TO
RESTRUCTURE THE EMPLOYER'S
REPORT- AND FOR THE EMPLOYERS TO
COMPLY WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL
DATA ELEMENTS AND THEN THE
EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO COMPLY. SO
THOSE ARE REALLY THE THINGS
THREE THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT
WHEN MAKING ANY LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE OR IMPACT OF THE
EMPLOYER- WE HAVE A LOOK- AND
ANALYZED PRIOR LEGISLATION
THAT'S ASKED US TO EXPAND THE
BASE WAGE FILE SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WERE UNFAMILIAR
WITH DOING THE ANALYSIS WE
HAVEN'T DONE A MAJOR DATABASE
RESTRUCTURE SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE- BUT- IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE COSTED OUT
MULTIPLE TIMES DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE ASK WAS FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
OTHER STATES HAVE BEEN DOING-
DIFFERENT THINGS IN THE SAME
ARENA- SOME STATES REQUIRING
EMPLOYERS TO REPORT
ELECTRONICALLY WHICH AS YOU
MENTIONED FACILITATES- EASIER-
REPORTING OF. DATA ELEMENTS AS
THEY CHANGE YOUR EYES. ARE
EXPANDED- CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
AN ELECTRONIC REPORTING MANDATE
IN PLACE- TWELVE STATES COLLECT
ONE OR MORE OF TEN DIFFERENT
ENHANCED DATA VARIABLES. AND
THERE WAS A STATE SURVEY IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT LOOKED AT
THE USES FOR THOSE EXPANDED
VARIABLES WHICH WAS ALIGNING
EDUCATION WORKFORCE TRAINING-
SUPPLY WITH EMPLOYER DEMANDS FOR
LABOUR DEVELOPING MORE EFFECTIVE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAMS.
PROVIDING CONSUMER INFORMATION
FOR IMPROVED DECISION MAKING-
SUPPORTING MORE EFFICIENT LABOR
MARKETS STRENGTHENING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS. AND HELPING
BUSINESSES COMPETE MORE
EFFECTIVELY IN THEIR REGION-
ALSO IMPROVING CORPORATE HIRING
AND RETENTION PRACTICES THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS AND PROMOTING
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY IN PUBLIC
SPENDING ON EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS- MANY STATES
HAVE REPLACED THEIR DECADES OLD
TECHNOLOGY WITH MODERN DATABASES
THAT ARE FLEXIBLE AND HANDLING
MONEY. FOR CATIONS- AND WE ALSO
HAVE- STATES THAT HAVE
RESTRUCTURED THEIR REPORTING
MECHANISMS TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL- DATA ELEMENTS IT'S-
IF YOU NEED IN THE PROCESS OF.
NINETY PROJECT NOW TO UPGRADE
YOUR SYSTEMS- YOU KNOW IT IT IT
HAS A VARIETY OF SYSTEMS-
DEPENDING ON AND THEN THEY'RE
SOMEWHAT PROGRAM SPECIFIC WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF LOOKING AT A
RE IMAGINED BUSINESS SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION. PROJECT FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND THE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAMS THE BASE
WAGE DATABASE IS A REPOSITORY
THAT THEY TIE INTO BUT IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY IN THAT. PROJECT. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN ANSWER
THIS BUT- IF WE WERE TO PURSUE-
A LEGISLATIVE EFFORT TO EXPAND
THE WHAT I CALL LITTLE LABOR
MARKET INFORMATION SYSTEM I
GUESS YOU WOULD CALL THE BASE
WAGE FILE. TO INCLUDE A LITTLE
LIMITED DATA POINTS ADDITIONAL
DATA POINTS BUT BUT DATA POINTS
THAT WILL AT LEAST GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO MEASURE. THE
PERFORMANCE AND SUCCESS OR
FAILURE OF OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. FOR PROGRAMS IN
TERMS OF RETRAINING. OF. HOW HOW
MUCH LEAD TIME WITH THE EDT
REQUIRE FOR THAT SORT OF
LEGISLATION TO TAKE EFFECT IN
ORDER TO GIVE YOU THE TIME TO.
OF SYNC THROUGH APPROPRIATELY
DESIGNED AS YOU'RE MOVING
THROUGH YOUR OTHER I. T.
MODERNIZATION PROGRAMS. I WOULD
DEFER THAT QUESTION TORE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY FOLKS AND
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU IT DOES HAVE A PROGRAM
COMPONENT THAT I CAN SPEAK TO
WHEN WE WENT TO ELECTRONIC
REPORTING WHICH WAS REALLY
MOVING OUR EMPLOYERS OFF OF
PAPER WE TOOK A TWO AND A HALF
YOUR LEAD TIME AND THAT WAS FOR
MARKETING AND OUTREACH IT WAS
ALSO TO ALLOW EMPLOYERS TIME TO
MODIFY THEIR SYSTEMS TO
ACCOMMODATE ELECTRONIC REPORTING
SH AND A LOT OF THE SAME
CONSIDERATIONS ARE AT PLAY HERE-
WE WOULD NEED TO REPROGRAM OUR
LEGACY SYSTEMS. MODIFY EXISTING
DATABASES REPORTING STRUCTURES
WE WOULD NEED TO ESTABLISH
TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
MAINTENANCE AND LOOK AT DATA
STORAGE. SO INTERNALLY WE HAVE
TO DEVELOP A MARKETING AND
OUTREACH PLAN TO LET EMPLOYERS
KNOW- WHAT THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
WERE AND WE WOULD HAVE TO TRAIN
OUR STAFF IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
EMPLOYERS IN THIS NEW EFFORT.
FROM THE EMPLOYER SIDE- THERE
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL COST YOU
PROBABLY CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
REPORT THE DATA ELEMENTS AND
THEY WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO.
RESTRUCTURE AND MODIFY THEIR
INTERNAL- PAYROLL REPORTING
SYSTEMS AND THEN RELATED TO THAT
WE ALSO HAVE PAYROLL AGENTS AND
SOFTWARE VENDORS WHO SUPPLY
PAYROLL REPORTING- TECHNOLOGY
AND THEY WOULD ALSO NEED LATE
LEAD TIME. WE'D ALSO PROBABLY
NEED TO LOOK AT SOME GOOD- TOP
NOTCH- MARKETING AND OUTREACH
MATERIALS TO MAKE SURE THAT
EMPLOYERS KNEW WHAT THEY WERE
REPORTING AND THAT THERE WERE
NOT ANY QUESTIONS- SO WE DIDN'T
END UP IN THE SAME PLACE WE
WOULD WANT THEM TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED. TO
BE ABLE TO REPORT THE
INFORMATION THAT THE LABOR
MARKET WAS REQUESTING- WE NEED
SOME STANDARDIZATION AROUND
OCCUPATIONAL CODING- WE'VE GOT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF IN-
COMPENSATION MODELS- THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED- AND THAT
WOULD TAKE SOME- EXTENSIVE
MARKETING AND OUTREACH. JUST
CURIOUS THE TWO AND A HALF YEARS
THAT YOU PROGRAM FOR THAT
PARTICULAR THE CHANGE THAT YOU
REFERRED TO WAS THE TWO AND A
HALF YEARS ADEQUATE OR DID YOU
TEND TO. RUN BEYOND THE TWO AND
A HALF YEARS IN ORDER FOR. THE
MEDICATION THAT WAS MOSTLY A
MARKETING AND OUTREACH PLAN- AND
AGAIN NINETY NINE POINT 9%
COMPLIANCE AT THE END OF THE TWO
AND A HALF YEARS. WE HAD A YEAR
AND A HALF BEFORE WE DID- WE-
DID IT IN PHASES. SO WE REALLY
HAD A YEAR AND A HALF OF
MARKETING AND THEN WE
IMPLEMENTED FOR LARGE EMPLOYERS
AND THEN THE SECOND YEAR WE
IMPLEMENTED FOR SMALL EMPLOYERS
SO IT GAVE US A TRANSITION
PERIOD. EXCELLENT WELL YOU KNOW
PART OF MY CONCERN IS. THE
EIGHTY D. IS THE ONLY DATA
REPOSITORY THAT WE ESSENTIALLY
HAVE AT LEAST THE ONES THAT ARE
THE DATA REPOSITORY THAT
SOMEWHAT ACCESSIBLE. AND WITHOUT
SOME ADDITIONAL DATA FROM THE E.
D. IT SEEMS TO ME IN THE
TESTIMONY TODAY SORT OF SUPPORTS
THIS THAT WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO EVALUATE OUR
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS. TO
GIVE THEM AN A B. C. D. OR F.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T REALLY TELL
WHETHER THEY'RE DOING THE JOB
THAT THEY'VE TOLD THE STUDENT
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO WITH
THE TRAINEE. OR THE JOB THAT
THEY'VE TOLD US THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
MONEY THAT WE- PROVIDED THROUGH
GRANTS TO FACILITATE THE
TRAINING SO WE'LL HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH THIS SITE LISTEN I
RECOGNIZED THE BURDEN THAT. THE
EDT IS UNDER PARTICULARLY NOW
AND THIS IS PROBABLY NOT THE
TIME TO ADD MORE TO IT BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO. HAVE A CONTINUED
THE CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES ON ON HOW WE CAN
PLAN FORWARD. TO MAYBE ADD SOME
DATA POINTS TO THE BASE WAGE
FILE OR WHEREVER IT NEEDS TO GO
SO THAT WE CAN PERFORM THIS SORT
OF EVALUATION AND ASSESSMENT. OF
OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
BUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
YOU'VE BEEN VERY INFORMATIVE.
DID I FEEL THERE'S SOMETHING-
YOU DID ASK US- FOR POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES- IN ORDER TO.
SMOOTH THE TRANSITION PER SE-
YOU KNOW- DEBILITY DEVELOP TOOLS
AND SYSTEMS FOR SOME
OCCUPATIONAL ANGIOGRAPHIC
COATING MAKING NOT SIMPLER-
IDENTIFYING FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR STATE YOU WHY UPGRADES
BECAUSE THIS WOULD BE AN
UPGRADE- WHICH IS PROBLEMATIC
WITH FEDERAL FUNDING IT WOULD
REQUIRE STATE FUNDING AND
ENHANCED WAGE RECORDS- COULD
REDUCE THE EMPLOYER SURVEY
BURDEN- YOU KNOW ELLEN MY G.
DOES QUITE A BIT OF STARVING OUT
TO TRY TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU PRODUCT TODAY. AND
YOU KNOW THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
ADDRESS THAT WHICH WHICH YOU'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED. YOU ALSO ASK
US IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO REQUIRE
YOU TO DO TO SECURE DATA ON
ENTREPRENEURS AND GIG ECONOMY
EMPLOYEES- RIGHT NOW IF THE GIG
GIG IS SUCH A BIG WORD- IT
COVERS MANY MANY DIFFERENT TYPES
OF EMPLOYMENT- AND RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN- WORKER AND A SERVICE
PROVIDER. EDT CURRENTLY COLLECTS
DATA FROM EMPLOYERS ABOUT THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND. IF- IF. A WORKER
IS TO BE AN EMPLOYEE THAT
INFORMATION IS REPORTED TO EDG.
SHE HAS MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD SO- THERE
ARE. REPORTING MECHANISMS
AVAILABLE FOR THE GIG ECONOMY
EMPLOYEES. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THREE FUTURE HELP THEM LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A AN ITEM
THAT TO THE EXTENT THE
LEADERSHIP IN THE LEGISLATURE
WISHES TO PURSUE IT WILL NEED TO
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO WORK
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE BUT
ABSOLUTELY DEPENDS ON OUR
WORKING RELATIONSHIP- AND HELP
FROM YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
GOVERNOR SO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY TODAY. IT
WAS WELL THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
PANELIST MARIA MORADO EXECUTIVE
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR EDUCATIONAL
SERVICESCALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
THANK YOU MA'AM GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
AFTERNOON HOW ARE YOU THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME. I'M BACK I
APOLOGIZE I'M A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS SO BEAR WITH ME HERE HI
VERY EXCITED TO BE WITH YOU THIS
AFTERNOON AND GET TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
BEEN MEASURING PERFORMANCE AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AS
YOU ARE LIKELY VERY AWARE WE
HAVE A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
OPPORTUNITY COLLEGES ALL ACROSS
THE STATE. I'M IN SEVENTY THREE
LOCALLY ELECTED DISTRICT SERVING
ROUGHLY TWO MILLION STUDENTS
ANNUALLY- SO WHAT WE I IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I'LL
START THERE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE LAUNCHED THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS I'M VERY
FOCUSED OUTCOMES ORIENTED
STUDENT CENTERED AGENDA. THAT
THAT PROMPTED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
WHAT WE CALL OUR STUDENTS
SUCCESS METRICS THE STUDENT
SUCCESS METRICS I'M NOT AS
STUDENTS PROGRESS AND OUTCOMES
ACROSS A RANGE OF. MILESTONES
FROM EXPLORATION AND ENROLLMENT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH Q. OUTCOMES
AND EMPLOYMENT FOR OUR CAREER
TECHNICAL WORK FOR STUDENTS-
THROUGH THIS EFFORT WE HAVE BEEN
REALLY FOCUSED ON THREE KEY
AREAS- ONE MAINTAINING A FOCUS
FOR OUR STUDENTS WHAT IS OUR JOB
OUR JOB IS TO PRODUCE THESE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS AND ENSURE
THAT. WE ARE MEETING THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE STUDENTS WHO
COME TO US AND THE STATE'S
INVESTMENTS SECOND WE ARE
FOCUSED ON TRANSPARENCY THE
STUDENT SUCCESS METRICS HI IT IS
AVAILABLE ON A PUBLIC FACING
DASHBOARD ALONG WITH A HANDFUL
OF OTHER DASHBOARDS THAT INCLUDE
EVALUATION AND OUTCOMES FOR ALL
OF OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. I AND MANY OF OUR KEY
REFORM INITIATIVES SUCH AS
GUIDED PATHWAYS AND OTHER
EFFORTS- AND THEN LASTLY THE
THIRD COMPONENT THAT WE REALLY
TRY TO MAINTAIN A FOCUS ON ITS
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT AND
IMPACT AGAIN IN THE SPIRIT OF
BEING FULLY TRANSPARENT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALSO
NOT USING THIS DATA. OR WHAT I
APPRECIATED HEARING YOUR
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT WE'RE NOT USING
IT FOR THE GOTCHA MOMENTS REALLY
USING IT FOR INFORMING HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE AND. GET
BETTER WE HAVE TO MAKE IT
TRANSPARENT WE HAVE TO RIGHT
WITH DAY AND THEN WE HAVE TO.
I'M WHERE THOSE FOR POINTS ARE
IN PROCESS IS NOT. IN OUR STATE.
AND REALLY MAKE SURE THE WE ARE
FORWARD AND I'M TRYING TO
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES SH I
SPECIFIC OR THE WORKFORCE DATA
COMPONENTS- JUST HEARING A
LITTLE BIT OF THE CONVERSATION
THAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING THUS FAR
I WANTED TO HIT ON A COUPLE OF
KEY POINTS. YOU'VE BEEN NOTING
THAT- THE CHALLENGE THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN OUR UNDERSTANDING WHERE
THE OCCUPATIONS WHAT IS THE
LOCAL LABOR MARKET DATA AND
WHETHER OR NOT OUR TRAINING
PROGRAMS. ARE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY MEET THOSE NEEDS
WHAT I WOULD POINT ZERO IS OUR
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE.
INVESTED IN ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S REALLY FOCUSED
ON IDENTIFYING AND WORKING WITH
OUR REGIONAL LABOR MARKET DATA
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
WORKFORCE- WITH OUR WORKFORCE
PARTNERS- AND REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHO. WHO IS THE
EMPLOYER BASED- WITHIN THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND REGIONS WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AND HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED TO. OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE REGIONAL
AND- COMMUNITY. COLLEGE
WORKFORCE. I SH WHAT I WOULD
ALSO POINT. IS YOU KNOW A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT OUR FIRST SPEAKER
CAN RAINING NOTED. WHICH IS THAT
THERE IS DEATH- THERE IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THIS THAT
IS LOCAL BOOTS ON THE GROUND
PERSON TO PERSON INTERACTION SH
THE LABOR MARKET DATA TELLS US.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT
FIND WHEN WE LOOK WITHIN THE
REGION HOWEVER IT'S BY TALKING
TO INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE MORE NUANCED.
SKILLS COMPETENCIES THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR THE OCCUPATION IS
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO. HELP
THE OTHER PIECE OF THAT ALSO IS
THAT EVERY STUDENT WHO COMES TO
US HAS A UNIQUE SET OF
BACKGROUND EXPERIENCES. AND
RESUMES AND SO WE ARE
CONTINUALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW DO WE ADAPT. OUR
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS WERE JUST
IN TME TRAINING THAT WILL
ENABLE INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE OUT
AND PROGRESS WITHIN THEIR CAREER
TRAJECTORY. WITHOUT FORCING THEM
TO REMAIN OUT WITHIN AN
EDUCATIONAL TRAINING PROGRAM FOR
LONGER THAN THEY NEED TO. RIGHT
SO. THAT IT REQUIRES A LITTLE
BIT MORE NUANCED INTERACTION
BOTH WITH THE EMPLOYER AT THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT AND THEN WITH
OUR INSTRUCTIONAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS- HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND HOW EFFECTIVE
OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
ARE AT PLACING STUDENTS WITHIN
THOSE OCCUPATIONS AND WITHIN
THE- INDUSTRY SECTORS. WE HAVE
WHAT WE CALL THE C. T. E.
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES SURVEY. I
THIS IS A SURVEY SURVEYS HIS
NAME. THAT WE ADMINISTERED ZERO-
THE MAJORITY OF OUR C. T.
COMPLETE- STUDENTS SO ANYONE WHO
HAS. ENROLLED IN AND COMPLETED A
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS. I
WE WOULD RECEIVE ROUGHLY A 25%
RESPONSE RATE IN WHAT WE SEE
THERE IS THATSTUDENTS TO
COMPLETE A TRAINING PROGRAM AND
ACTUALLY MOVE INTO THEIR FIELD
OF STUDY DO YOU SEE INCREASES IN
EARNINGS EARLY SIGNIFICANCE.
BETWEEN SEVEN AND EIGHT DOLLAR
INCREASES IN EARNINGS- AND
PROMOTIONS WHAT I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT HERE THOUGH IS THAT
YOU KNOW WE ARE COUPLING THIS
INFORMATION WITH. OUR STUDENT
SUCCESS METRIC INFORMATION DATA
SHARING AGREEMENTS WITH U. D. D.
AND OTHER. ODD MORE KIND
DEFINABLE. HARDER HARD AT ALL-
THAT DAY. IF YOU WELL RECCA. THE
FEEDING THURSDAY IS IT STILL
RECORD OR IT'S AS TAKE YOU
REPORT IT ENDED. RECALL IT'S NOT
AS- VALIDATE. I NEED IT HAVE THE-
OR THOSE HI. WHO WERE. TO SURVEY
VERSUS WHO DID REST RESPOND TO
THE SURVEY I'M SO WE TAKE ALL OF
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AS WE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF
POTENTIAL. AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE NEED WITHIN OUR SYSTEM SH-
THE LAST THING I WANT TO FOCUS
ON AND THEN I AM. A MUCH BETTER
WITH YOU IN A- THE LAST THING I
WANT TO FOCUS ON IS OUR
PARTNERSHIP AND RELATIONSHIP.
AGAIN GOING BACK TO OUR OPENING
SPEAKER THAT REALLY TALKED ABOUT
THIS EVOLUTION ON. BOTH OUR
WORKFORCE AND THE ECONOMY AS
WELL AS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED WITHIN
OUR RESPECTIVE SYSTEMS. FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM WE ARE
CONTINUALLY WRESTLING WITH HOW
DO WE ADAPT OUR DELIVERY
MODALITIES. IN ORDER TO BEST
MEET THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
GIVEN WHERE OUR CURRENT ECONOMY
IS AND WHERE IT IS HEADED. RIGHT
IT ISN'T THE FUTURE OF WORK
REMOTE WORK IS HERE RIGHT NOW
RIGHT THERE ARE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES AND SO
WHEN EVEN WHEN WE THINK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW- MAPPING OUT TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO REGIONAL ECONOMIES
WHAT WE ALSO HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT IN THAT PORTFOLIO IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WILL NOW BE WORKING REMOTES. AND
OR WHO WILL HAVE OCCUPATIONS
THAT. ARE NOT NECESSARILY PLACE
BALANCED- AND SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
CONTINUALLY WRESTLING WITH AND
AGAIN IN ORDER TO ADAPT-
TRAINING PROGRAMS. TO HAVE JUST
IN TIME. I AM VERY TAILORED.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG
ATTAINMENT AND- IN. GOING LIKE
TO CALL IT I'M ARE LOOKING AT
HOW DO WE INCREASE- ARKHAM. AND
NEXT. AROUND EACH FOCUSING COM.
ARE RATHER THAN FULL OCCUPATIONS
WHAT ARE THE UNIQUE SKILL SETS
THAT I EMPLOYERS ARE ASKING US
FOR AND HOW DO WE FIGURE OUT
MODALITIES FOR DELIVERING THOSE.
POPPINS I IN A WAY THAT-
STUDENTS CAN LEARN AND MOVE ON
AND LEARN AND MOVE ON AND
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE AND RE
ENGAGE. BOTH WITHIN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AS WELL AS IN
THE WORK FORCE THE LAST THING
I'LL ALSO POINT HERE IS THAT
WHAT WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
WRESTLE WITH THIS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE ARE VALIDATING.
AUGMENTING AND ENHANCING THE
EXPERIENCES THE LIVES. IT WORK
EXPERIENCES THAT- INDIVIDUALS
ARE HAVING WHERE THEY ARE
LEARNING ON THE JOB SO WHETHER
THAT'S A PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS OR
WHETHER THAT'S CREDIT FOR PRIOR
LEARNING REALLY MAKING SRE THAT
WE ARE. NOT ASKING STUDENTS TO
REPEAT THINGS THAT THEY HAVE
ALREADY MASTERED THAT REALLY
ENSURING THAT THEY CAN'T THEY
HAVE VEHICLES FOR DEMONSTRATING
MASTERY- AND PROVIDING-
PROVIDING THE TRANSCRIPTS FOR
THOSE EFFORTS. ALL OF THIS TO
SAY- WE AREN'T I WOULD. HIGHLY
COGNISANT AND WORK OUT RIGHT
ALONGSIDE OUR PARTNERS IN
WORKFORCE AND EDT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE EVOLVE AS A
SYSTEM OUR DATA SYSTEMS ARE
CAPTURING THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION THAT CAN HELP US
WITH CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENTS. I
AM ALSO WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
J. IDENTIFY WHERE WE NEED TO
EVOLVE AS THE SYSTEMS TO BEST
MEET THE. NEEDS ARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AND I WILL PAUSE
THERE. LET ME JUST SAY DID A
GREAT JOB YOU SHOULDN'T BE
NERVOUS THANK YOU. YOU KNOW THE-
COMMON QUESTION THAT I MADE AT
THE OUTSET HAVING TO DO WITH
THEM. WHEN I ASK. IT'S ACTUALLY
A LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO
THE PERSON AND ONE OF OUR
REGIONS OF THE STATE OR I WOULD
GO TO FIND OUT ABOUT A
PARTICULAR JOB SKILL THAT WAS
REQUIRED WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WAS A JOB SKILLS INVENTORY IT
WAS THE LOCAL WORKFORCE PERSON
WHO SAID I HAVE NO IDEA. AND MY
RESPONSE WAS WELL IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHO DOES. AND THAT'S THE G.
THAT'S THE GENESIS OF MY OF MY
CONCERN AND REALLY THE- THE
GENESIS OF THIS HEARING WAS TO.
RECOGNIZE THE OUTSTANDING JOB
FRANKLY THAT THE DVD DOES
OUTSTANDING JOB AT OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS AROUND THE
STATE DO AND FRANKLY THE
EXTRAORDINARY JOB AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO BOTH IN
READYING STUDENTS FOR. FOUR YEAR
PROGRAMS ELSEWHERE AND IN THE
NON DEGREE CTE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
WERE SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT
AND SO WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
DO THROUGH THIS HEARING IN THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND WHAT FOLLOWS
FROM THIS IS TO. TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT IMPROVEMENTS WE CAN
MAKE TO THE SYSTEM INCLUDING
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE DATA
COLLECTION PROCESS AND THE DATA
AVAILABLE TO HELP YOU CONTINUE
TO DO THE INCREDIBLE JOB THAT-
YOU ALL. IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM DO
EVERY DAY FOUR OF STUDENTS IN
AND TRAINEES IN OUR STATE. YOU
MENTIONED THE C. T. OUTCOME
SURVEY AND YOU. SEPARATELY
IDENTIFIED WHEN YOU HAVE A-
7575% OR SO NOT RESPONDING RATE
YOU KNOW THE VALIDATION ISSUE IN
THEM AND THE BIAS QUESTIONS BUT-
THE ONES THAT DID RESPOND SO
THEY SHOW A WAGE INCREASE. BUT
ARE YOU ABLE TO TELL FROM THE
RESPONSES TO THE C. T. OUTCOME
SURVEY WHETHER THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO THE 25% OF ACTUALLY
COMPLETED THE SURVEY. SECURE
JOBS IN THE SPECIFIC FIELD FOR
WHICH THEY WERE TRAINED. WE ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT INFORMATION
AGAIN SELF REPORTED ON BUT THAT
WAS REALLY ONE OF THE GENESIS OF
THE OUTCOME SURVEY WAS WANTING
TO UNPACK AND GET CLOSER TO ZERO
WHETHER OR NOT STUDENTS BELIEVE
THEY ARE WORKING IN THE INDUSTRY
SECTOR THAT THEY TRAINED FOR ALL
POINT TO THE EXAMPLE THE
QUALIFICATION I BUT THERE IS A
POINT TO THE EXAMPLE- IMA HAVE
TRAINED IN NINETEEN. BUT MY
OCCUPATION IS IN HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE I WORK IN THE HEALTHCARE
SECTOR BECAUSE I WORK IN IT IN
THE HEALTHCARE SECTOR RIGHT SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
FOR THE SURVEY EVEN AS AN
IMPERFECT TOOL IT'S STILL A
REALLY CRITICAL TOOL FOR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO STUDENTS AND WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE WORKING
WITHIN THAT SECTOR THAT THEY
TRAIN FOR OUT WHERE THEY ARE
WORKING WITHIN THE SECTOR THEY
TRAIN FOR WE SEE HIGHER.
INCREASES IN EARNINGS AND AN ACT
YEAH HIGHER INCREASES IN
EARNINGS. AND I GUESS THE TEST
IS HOW YOU HOW YOU MOVE BEYOND
THE C. T. OUTCOME SURVEY TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE FURTHER
SPECIFIC JOB NEEDS ARE IN A
PARTICULAR REGION BEYOND GOING
EMPLOYER TO EMPLOYER AND I
REALIZED I MEAN THAT'S THE- THE
CALIBRATE. PROCESS WAS TO GO
REGIONAL AND TALK TO EMPLOYERS
TO DEAL WITH SPECIFIC NEEDS AND
DESIGN TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR
SPECIFIC. NEEDS AND THAT'S FINE.
BUT THAT'S IT'S- TO- INSTITUTE.
THAT IF I CAN USE THE STATE AS
AN INSTITUTION AND TAKE IT
STATEWIDE. RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
SORT OF SPECIFIC. TO
RELATIONSHIPS OF LOCAL
COMMUNICATION OCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE WITH LOCAL
EMPLOYER GROUPS LOCAL EMPLOYERS.
AND MAY BE A HYPERACTIVE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD THAT
IS REALLY INTERESTED IN THAT IN
MY CORRECT. I THINK IT'S I THINK
YES AND NO RIGHT I THINK IT'S A
BOTH DAN. I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE DEFINITELY
HAVE IS A SYSTEM. THAT MAKES IT
HARDER FOR US TO BOTH CAPTURE
THE DATA AS WELL AS MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS. IS THAT WE HAVEN'T
FULLY BUILT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
EFFECTIVELYSUPPORT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- AND BY THAT I MEAN
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK FORCE AN
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY. FINANCE
ENGAGEMENT HAPPENING THROUGH
WORK STUDY THROUGH COOPERATIVE
WORK EXPERIENCE- AND OTHER TYPES
OF EMPLOYMENT ACTIVITIES THAT
AREN'T ALWAYS- WELL CONNECTED.
TO THE WORKFORCE INFRASTRUCTURE-
EITHER BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED ON A CAMPUS WHERE THE
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS. SO GO
BACK TO WHERE YOU MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THE INDIVIDUAL WHO SAID I
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO FIND THAT.
EVEN THOUGH I'M FAMILIAR WITH-
IN YOUR REGION. YOU HAVE SOME
AMAZING WORKFORCE PROFESSIONALS
THERE WHO ARE WELL CAPTAIN AND
HAVE LOTS OF REALLY ROBUST
NETWORK SH- IT'S NOT AS DIFFUSED
WITHIN OUR SYSTEM. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE THINKS
ABOUT OR IS FAMILIAR WITH AND
THAT CREATES PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
LIMITATIONS. AND SO THIS IS
WHERE I WOULD POINT YOU IT IS
LOCALIZED AND WE HAVE TO BE
BUILDING THE INSTITUTIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT ENABLES
MORE OF OUR INSTITUTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THE WORK FORCE
DISCUSSIONS AND NOT BASEBALL'S
BIKER CATION. THERE ARE STUDENTS
WHO ARE WORKFORCE IN THEIR
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT BECAUSE
EVERYONE COMES OR INSTITUTION
LOOKING FOR CAREER STABILITY AND
CAREER GROWTH. AND I GUESS IS
THE GOVERNOR'S A. CRADLE TO
CAREER. DAY ASH BOARD- IS BUILT
TO BIG. ROBUST AND FULLY UP THAT
WILL UNDER HELP IN CONNECTING.
THE DOTS HERE. EAST WITHIN THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AND THEN BUT
THAT'S OF COURSE WHY WERE
EXPLORING WITH EDT SOMETHING ON
A BROADER SCALE TO DRAW. ALL
EMPLOYERS INTO THIS PROCESS TO
DRAW ALL OF CALIFORNIA INTO THIS
PROCESS AND THEY HAVE SOME
RATHER SPECIFIC REGIONAL JOB
NEEDS IDENTIFIED BY REGION SO
THAT THOSE OF YOU IN THE IN THE
TRAINING BUSINESS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND OTHERWISE WE'LL HAVE TARGETS
TO LOOK TOWARD PROGRAMS TO
DESIGN THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO A
REGION AND THEN OUT COMES. TO
MEASURE AND BE- GRATED ON SO.
GREAT JOB ANYTHING ELSE. HI I
THINK THAT PRETTY MUCH COVERS IT
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO JOIN YOU THIS AFTERNOON WELL
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. OUR NEXT
PANELIST TERROR ARMSTRONG DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF TECHNICAL BRANCH CIO
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. THERE
YOU ARE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS
FOR THE INTRO SO GLAD TO BE HERE
TODAY I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
GENERALLY THAT ARE OUR PROGRAM
IS MUCH DIFFERENT AND THAT WE
BASE OUR PROGRAM- THROUGH THE
LENSES OF CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.
SO BASICALLY THE BUSINESSES AND
ENTITIES THEY COME TO US FOR
RESOURCES TO TRAIN THEIR CURRENT
AND OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE SO THAT
THEY CAN HAVE SKILLED WORKERS
AND BE COMPETITIVE BIKE WITHIN
THEIR INDUSTRY. SO ALL OF OUR
CONTRACTS ARE SUPPOSED TO DO
WITH EMPLOYERS MEDIAN THAT. A
CERTAIN WAGE BENCHMARK AND THEN
BEING RETAINED FOR A PERIOD OF
NINETY DAYS- BEFORE THAT THEY
CAN BE DONE WITH THE TRAINING
CONTRACT AND THEN- PAYMENT. SO
JUST KIND OF REITERATE WE ARE
PERFORMANCE BASED CONTRACTING
KIND OF MACHINE HERE- SO IF YOU
DON'T TRAIN EMPLOYEE FOR A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS AND THEN
REACH HAND. ROOM ONLY FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME. AND THEN MEET
THE WAGE FOR THAT PARTICULAR
EMPLOYEE THEY WILL NOT RECEIVE
PAYMENT FOR THAT. ANY SO WE DO
HAVE A VERY HIGH DEMAND ETP'S SO
WE DO SET THESE FILTERS ON THESE
PRIORITIES AND BENCHMARKS SO ONE
THAT WE DO CONCENTRATE ON IS
LOOKING AT INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
FACING AN OUT OF STATE
COMPETITION- SUCH AS LIKE A
MANUFACTURING AND CONSTRUCTION-
WE DO A LOT ALSO LOOKING AT
HEALTH CARE AND TECHNICAL
SERVICES- THE NDTV ALSO SETS UP
THESE PRIORITY PROGRAMS AND WE
CHANGES EACH FISCAL YEAR BASED
ON CALIFORNIA- NEEDS OF
POPULATIONS AND BUSINESSES- TO
HELP THEM- YOU KNOW TRAINEES
ENTITIES THAT WE LOOK AT. ARE
THE TRAINING NEW HIRES- PROGRAMS
FOR INCENTIVES- FOR TRAINING
VETERANS AND SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESSES. AS WELL AS LOOKING
AT THOSE WORK PLACES THAT ARE IN
THE HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT AREAS. SO
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT ANNUALLY
ETP IS- FUNNY APPROXIMATELY
NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EACH YEAR AND WITHIN THOSE
NINETY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
REACHING ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
BUSINESSES- AND I WOULD SAY
WITH. LOOKING AT JUST A SIXTY
JUST THIS LAST YEAR AND THOSE
NINETY THOUSAND ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND WERE IN SMALL BUSINESS
AREAS AND OF ALMOST TEN THOUSAND
OR INDIA HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
LOCATIONS SO WE DON'T HAVE A
DISCONNECT WITH YOU. WE GOT WE
HAVE A LOT OF INCOME BUT INCOME
IN TRAINING HERE I MEAN AND WE
EVEN LOOK AT THE- OCCUPATIONS
THAT THEY'RE PLANNING TO TRAIN
BEFORE WE EVEN GET MY CONTRACT
AND LIKE WHAT THEIR CURRICULUM.
IS THAT THEY ARE NEEDING WITHIN
THEIR ENTITY- WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE NUMBER OF TRAINEES FOR THEIR
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE FOR EACH OF
THOSE TRAINEES. WHEN THEIR WAGES
ARE HOW MANY HOURS ARE BEING
TRAINED SO IT WE COLLECT A LOT
OF DATA. FOR ONE IT IT SOUNDS AS
IF YOU HAVE ACCESS TO BECAUSE OF
WHAT YOU DO. SORT OF A REGIONAL
NEEDS ASSESSMENT IN TERMS OF
JOBS IS THAT CORRECT I MEAN DO
YOU KNOW WHAT JOBS WHAT TRAINING
IS NEEDED IN PARTICULAR REGIONS
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU DO. WELL SO
WHEN THE EXCUSE COME TO US THEY
ARE MOSTLY INCUMBENT WORKERS SO
THEY'RE ALREADY IN THE
OCCUPATIONS OF THE OCCUPATIONS
AND THE TRAINING THAT THEY'RE
GIVING THOSE OCCUPATIONS IN
THOSE TRAINEES. THEY'RE ALREADY
TIED TOGETHER I MEAN THAT'S HOW
OUR PROGRAM IS MOSTLY DESIGNED.
I SEE AFTER YOU DON'T FOR
EXAMPLE YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO.
BECAUSE OF YOUR INVOLVEMENT
LET'S SAY IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO. TELL THAT THERE LET'S SAY
YOUR TRAINING YOU HAVE INCOME OF
WORKERS THAT ARE COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGISTS TECHNOLOGY TYPES
IT TYPES YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
TELL WHETHER THERE IS AN UNMET
NEED OF TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY I.
T. TYPES IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF WHERE YOU
ARE AND WHAT YOU DO. NOW I'M BUT
WE DO HAVE LIKE A NEW HIRE OR
COMPONENT- TTP AND THAT WE
CANNOT TELL YOU KNOW IF THEIR
TRAINING AND WHERE THEY WERE
PLACED AT THE END WE DO TRACK
WAGES- BUT AGAIN WHEN YOU GO TO
THAT BASE WHICH FILE TO CHECK
THAT WAGE BUT WE DO NOT KNOW
THEIR OCCUPATION DO YOU HAVE THE
SAME LIMITATION THAT ALL THE
REST OF US HAVE BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE OF OUR- BASE
WAGE FILE. YEAH AND I LIKE YOUR
IDEA THERE FOR SURE. WHO WILL.
WHETHER THAT HAS ANY LEGS. YES
SO- I DO ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT- ONE OF ONE THINGS THAT WE
ARE ADDING TO OUR PROGRAM IS
COLLECTING THE WAGE AND ROMANCE
SO WHEN COMPANIES COME IN THEY
GET THEIR CONTRACT WITH US THEY
ENROLL THEIR TRAINEES AND THEN
AT THAT TIME THAT THEY WOULD
GIVE US THE WAGE FOR THAT
TRAINEE THEY WOULD PERFORM THEIR
TRAINING AND THEN THEY'D BE HELD
HER RETENTION PERIOD. AND THEN
WE CHECK THAT THEIR WAGE AND
THEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO MEASURE
WAGE PROGRESSION SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO ASCERTAIN
THE IMPACT AT LEAST THE TRAINING
AND THE RETENTION IS ON THAT
SINCE WE'RE GONNA COLLECT THE
BEFORE AND AFTER OF THAT WAGE.
EXCELLENT BOOK OF ONCE AGAIN YOU
KNOW WHAT JOBS THERE IN WHEN
YOU'RE PROVIDING THE TRAINING
YES YES GOOD. GOOD ANYTHING THAT
I FAILED TO ASK- I DID WANT TO
MENTION THAT- WE ARE WORKING
WITH YOU KNOW OUR OTHER LABOR
AGENCIES IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE'VE BUILT A NEW-
CONTRACTING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
WITH HAVING IN HOUSE STAFF YOU
KNOW WHO ARE BE ABLE TO
MANIPULATE IT SO WE CAN COLLECT
THAT DATA. COMPILED THAT DATA
AND STRATEGICALLY PLAN. YOU KNOW
FOR LOOKING AT WHAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS EACH FISCAL YEAR AND
BEYOND THAT SO THAT WE CAN HELP
THESE BUSINESSES AND THEIR
TRAINING. THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR WE
SHOULD CREATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME TO SPEND IT WITH US THIS
AFTERNOON ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S MOVE TO OUR SECOND
PANEL. AND THE PANELS ENTITLED
WAYS TO IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION
PROGRAM EVALUATION AND
PERFORMANCE REPORTING. IN OUR
FIRST PANELIST IS RACHEL VILSACK
SENIOR FELLOW NATIONAL SKILLS
COALITION. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROSS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE-
AS YOU MENTION MY NAME IS RACHEL
LITTLE SACK I'M A SENIOR FELLOW
AT NATIONAL SKILLS COALITION
WHICH IS A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN WASHINGTON
DC THAT BUILDS NETWORKS
REPRESENTING BUSINESSES WORKERS
COLLEGES COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
AND ADVOCATES WHO BELIEVE THAT
JOBS THAT REQUIRE HIGH QUALITY
SKILLS TRAINING ARE CRITICAL IN
HELPING MORE PEOPLE GAIN ACCESS
TO A BETTER LIFE AND MORE
BUSINESSES. SEE SUSTAINED GROWTH
BY THE WAY THIS MIAMI. THANK YOU
THIS PAST YEAR AND A HALF HAS
MAGNIFIED THE NEED FOR ACCURATE
TIMELY WORKFORCE DATA BOTH TO
GUY DISPLACED WORKERS TOWARDS
THE BEST QUALITY RETRAINING
PROGRAMS AND TO ENSURE DATA
INFORMED POLICY DECISIONS
SUPPORT AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TRADITIONAL LABOR MARKET
SOURCES ARE BEING COUPLED WITH
REAL TIME TOOLS TO ANALYZE THE
SKILLS AND CREDENTIALS NEEDED IN
FACTORS FACING SHORTAGES OF
TRAINED WORKERS OR TOWARDS
OCCUPATIONS WHERE A QUALITY
CREDENTIAL PUTS INDIVIDUALS ON A
CAREER PATHWAY TOWARDS A FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGE. NATIONAL SKILLS
COALITION HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
DOZENS OF STATES TO DEFINE
QUALITY CREDENTIALS PARTICULARLY
IN THE NON DEGREE OR NON CREDIT
SPACE AS THE SHORT TERM PROGRAMS
ARE SEEN BY WORKING ADULTS TO BE
A FLEXIBLE ON RAMP TO RESKILLING
FOR IN DEMAND JOBS AND STATES
SEE NON DEGREE PROGRAMS IS A KEY
COMPONENT TO REACH POST
SECONDARY ATTAINMENT GOALS AND
AS AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY RESPONSE
TO RECONNECTING WORKING ADULTS
TO FURTHER OUR SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
OPPORTUNITIES DATA ON JOB
OPENINGS IN EMPLOYER FEEDBACK ON
QUALITY CREDENTIALS IS EEDED-
IN AND FOR THIS WORK A LOCAL
INDUSTRY SECTOR PARTNERSHIPS ARE
TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
SHAPING RETRAINING STRATEGIES TO
MEET THEIR SKILLS NEEDS WHILE
PROVIDING PATHWAYS. FOR WORKERS
TO GET JOBS IN DEMAND. THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT NEW PARTNERSHIPS
AND HAVE NATURALLY HOWEVER
EXPANDED DURING THE PANDEMIC TO
SUPPORT EMPLOYERS WHO FACED
SHORTAGES FOR FRONTLINE WORKERS
AND THESE PARTNERSHIPS SHOULD
EXPAND TO OTHER SECTORS WHO NEED
SKILLED WORKERS. AND FOR LOCAL
BUSINESSES WHO WANT TO ADVANCE
THE SKILLS OF THEIR EXISTING
WORK FORCE TO RESPOND TO
WORKPLACE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH. DIGITAL AND TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGES MISTER RANEY SPOKE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
PARTNERSHIPS PARTICULARLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SH OBVIOUSLY
ADMINISTRATIVE WAGE RECORDS
SERVE AS A KEY RESOURCE FOR
UNDERSTANDING OF PARTICIPANTS
THE WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE FINDING
EMPLOYMENT. AS MISTAKE NUMBER
SHARED SOME STATES DO COLLECT
ADDITIONAL ITEMS IN THEIR BASE
WAGE FILES INCLUDING JOB TITLES
LOCATION OF WORK AN HOUR'S WORK
WHICH IS THE MOST COMMON
ENHANCEMENT AMONG STATES. A
QUARTERLY MEASUREMENTS OF ALL
WORDS WORKS CAN ALLOW FOR THE
CALCULATION OF AN HOURLY WAGE
RATES AS WELL AS PART TIME AND
FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT STATUS
WHICH CAN BE A HELPFUL SIGNAL OF
JOB QUALITY AS FULL TIME JOBS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO OFFER
BENEFITS. IN ADDITION REQUIRING
EMPLOYERS TO SUBMIT OCCUPATION
OR JOB TITLES ON THEIR WAGE
RECORDS CAN PROVIDE GREATER
CONTEXT ON WHAT AN INDIVIDUAL
DOES ON THE JOB THAN AN INDUSTRY
CODE WHICH IS MOST COMMONLY IS
USED TO SIGNIFY WHAT GOODS OR
SERVICES A BUSINESS PRIMARILY
ENGAGES IN CREATING OR
PROVIDING. OUR MOST RECENTLY THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON IS
REQUESTING OCCUPATIONAL DATA
FROM EMPLOYERS AS A PART OF
THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
REPORTING. THEIR LEGISLATIVE
BILL EXPLAINS THAT THIS WILL
ALLOW FOR MORE ACCURATE
OCCUPATIONAL TREND ANALYSES AND
MORE EFFECTIVE EVALUATIONS OF
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
AND WHETHER IT'S NOT DAILY TO
PARTICULAR OCCUPATIONS. I POINT
OUT THAT WAGE RECORD
ENHANCEMENTS MAY NOT HOWEVER
PROVIDE ALL OF THE INFORMATION
THAT BIKE MIGHT BE NEEDED TO
ASSESS CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRESSION IN WORK FORCE
PROGRAM SUCCESS. CERTAINLY IT
HELPS TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT WORK WELL
AND ACHIEVE SUCCESS FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF PARTICIPANTS LIKE
RECENT DISLOCATED WORKERS ARE
LONG TERM UNEMPLOYED BUT THE
DATA MAY NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INSIGHT INTO THE SKILLS THAT.
EDUCATION CERTIFICATIONS AND
WORK EXPERIENCE HELD BY
INDIVIDUALS THAT INFLUENCE
CAREER SUCCESS AND WHICH MIGHT
BE OBTAINED OUTSIDE OF
IMMEDIATE. OF THE IMMEDIATE WORK
FORCE PROGRAM BEING MASURED
HERE'S WHERE STATE LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEMS CAN PLAY A ROLE IN
SHOWING THAT EDUCATION TO WORK
FORCE AN EDUCATION TO WORK
FORCE. PROGRESSION THAT SOME
INDIVIDUALS MAY TAKE. AND THERE
CERTAINLY ARE STANDARD CONCERNS
OF DATA ERRORS TIMELINESS OF
AVAILABLE DATA AND LIMITED DATA
IF ANY ON THE OUTCOMES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT HOLD A
JOB COVERED BY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. NAMELY INDIVIDUALS
WHO WORK IN CONTRACT OR GIG
ROLES NORMAL OUTCOMES BE
COMPLETE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WORK OUTSIDE OF THE STATE UNLESS
THOSE STATES TO REQUIRE SIMILAR
WAGE RECORD ENHANCEMENTS. BY
SENATOR I THINK YOU FOR UP
LIFTING THE UNIQUE TIME WERE IN
AT THE BEGINNING OF YOUR OPENING
REMARKS WITH FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING AND
REALLY THE NEED TO MEET NEW
EMPLOYER DEMANDS AND DISSIPATED
FROM. WHAT WILL BE AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS. ALL PUBLIC DATA
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ARE CRITICAL
TO EVALUATING A FAR WORK FORCE
YOU SKILLS TRAINING POLICY
SUPPORTS AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY OR RECOVERY THAT
RECOGNIZES. AND UP LIFTS WORKERS
OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND WORKERS
WITH A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
LAST WHO HAVE SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS DURING
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF. AND
WHO WERE ALREADY STRUGGLING
RELATIVE TO OTHER WORKERS BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC EVEN BEGAN. GOOD
DATA CAN HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT IN TERMS OF CREATING
GREATER ACCESS TO WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS AND REPORTING THE
MEASURABLE ECONOMIC GAMES.
CAREER ADVANCE CAREER PATHWAYS
BUILD WEALTH AND EXPAND THE WELL
BEING OF WORKERS SHARE DATA.
SYSTEMS TOO ARE ARE CRITICAL TO
INFORM DECISION MAKING AND BOTH
DATA AND WELL DESIGNED SYSTEMS
MUST ALSO BE CAPABLE OF TRACKING
PROGRAM ACCESS. AND OUTCOMES
MEASURED BY RACE ETHNICITY AND
OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS THAT ALLOW
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROFESSIONALS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS BARRIERS
FOR UNDER REPRESENTED PEOPLE OF
COLOR ADDRESS ANY GAPS AND
MEASURE PROGRESS TOWARDS CLOSING
EQUITY GOALS. I'LL GIVE YOU A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF MINNESOTA
WHO REQUIRES DISAGGREGATED
PERFORMANCE DATA ON STATE FUNDED
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS BY RACE
ETHNICITY GENDER GEOGRAPHY AGE
EDUCATION AND HOUSING STATUS.
THE REPUBLIC DASHBOARD LOCATED
ON ITS DEPARTMENT OF EMPLOYMENT
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
WEBSITE. THE DASHBOARD NOT ONLY
TRACKS OUTCOMES BY RACE BUT ALSO
SOME SPECIFIC IMMIGRANT
SUBGROUPS PREVALENT WITHIN THE
STATE INCLUDING MOM IN SOMALI
IMMIGRANTS. PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES
IN CLUED SHORT MID LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT RETENTION FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO COMPLETED
TRAINING OR NOT. AND ATTEND A
CREDENTIAL OR NOT AS WELL AS PRE
AND POST WAGE COMPARISONS
REPORTING IS CODIFIED IN STATE
STATUTE IT'S MADE POSSIBLE BY
LEVERAGING PROGRAM DATA CAPTURED
THROUGH A SINGLE CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM WHICH IS USED BY ALL
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AREAS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ADMINISTER
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDED
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS OF
COURSE LINKING PROGRAM DATA TO
ADMINISTRATIVE WAGE RECORDS.
LASTLY AND FOR DATA TO BE USED
EFFECTIVELY IN CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS- OUTCOMES
DATA ESPECIALLY DISAGGREGATED
DATA MUST BE AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT AREAS
WHERE THE SERVICE DELIVERY TAKES
PLACE. NATIONAL SKILLS COALITION
HEARS FROM LOCAL PRACTITIONERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT. ACCESS
TO EMPLOYMENT AND WAGE OUTCOMES
FROM ADMINISTRATIVE RECORDS FOR
THE CUSTOMERS THEY SERVE IT'S
OFTEN NOT AVAILABLE AND
THEREFORE CAN'T BE USED TO
ASSESS WHAT'S WORKING WELL OR
NOT AT A LOCAL LEVEL. I MENTION
THIS BECAUSE ONE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUE OF EXPANDED. WORKFORCE
REPORTING IS THE PRACTITIONER
AND LOCALIZED INSIGHT THAT MIGHT
BE NEEDED TO HELP CONTEXTUALIZE
THE OUTCOMES THAT WERE SEEN IN
THE DATA WELL THE MINNESOTA
EXAMPLE I SURE DID NOT REQUIRE
REPORTING ON FULL TIME OR PART
TIME JOB STATUS IT WAS DEEMED
NECESSARY. TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO DID NOT FULLY
SEE THE SUCCESS OF THEIR
WORKFORCE TRAINING EFFORTS THAT
TOOK INDIVIDUALS FROM MULTIPLE
LOWER PAYING PART TIME JOBS TO A
FULL TIME JOB THAT OFFERED
HIGHER WAGES AND BENEFITS. SO
EXPANDED DATA COLLECTION AND
PUBLIC REPORTING HAS ALLOWED
STATES LIKE MINNESOTA TO MORE
ACCURATELY MEASURE HOW THE
PUBLIC WORKFORCE SYSTEM IS
MEETING THE STATE'S EQUITY WORK
FOR SCHOOLS. AND THESE EXPANDED
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES CAN BE USED
TO ADDRESS GAPS IN SERVICE
DELIVERY. OUT WHETHER WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS HELPED PARTICIPANTS
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND
INCOME GROWTH OVER TIME RATHER
THAN PROMOTING A JOBS FIRST
MENTALITY AND IF PROGRAMS OR
PROVIDERS AREN'T DEMONSTRATING
EFFECTIVENESS AND SHOULD CEASE
TO BE FUNDED. AND I'LL CONCLUDE
MY REMARKS THERE LOOKS FORWARD
TO THE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU I
WAS GOING TO ASK. WHAT OTHER
DATA POINTS MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO
US BUT I THINK OF YOU. WOUND UP
BY MENTIONING THOSE THE RACE
HOUSING ISSUES CREDENTIAL OR NOT
ITS CENTER IN OAKLAND THE LIST
THAT YOU MENTIONED. AND I
THOUGHT I CAUGHT YOU SAYING THAT
IT WAS USED FOR DATA POINTS
COLLECTED BY THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS AND HOW HOW
DID THAT WORK IN THE STATES THAT
THAT HAVE HAPPENED. SO IN STATES
WHERE ALL THIS WORK IS HAPPENING
AGAIN I TEND TO USE MINNESOTA AS
AN EXAMPLE HERE WHO'S REALLY
ADVANCED PUBLIC REPORTING OF
THESE OUTCOMES DATA. IS REALLY
EMBODYING WHAT THE DATA BEING
COLLECTED AT EITHER THAT LOCAL
WORK FORCE LEVEL OR FROM THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH MINISTER. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS SO IT'S
REALLY BUILT INTO A CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT CONTAINS.
A COMMON AND STANDARD
DEFINITIONS FOR ALL OF THESE
DATA ELEMENTS SO THAT AT THE END
OF THE DAY YOU CAN HAVE A PUBLIC
FACING. OUR TOOL A REPORT CARD
THAT'S COMPARING LIKE A DATA TO
LIKE DATA. AND I REALLY UP
LIFTED THE NEED TO DISAGGREGATE
THIS INFORMATION. YOU KNOW BY
THINGS LIKE RACE ETHNICITY
GENDER- AND SO ON. BECAUSE IT IS
THE RECOGNITION ALSO THAT
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SERVE
DIFFERENT- POPULATIONS. AND THAT
IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL AND USEFUL.
AS A PART OF THAT PUBLIC
REPORTING TO LOOK AT. AT WHO IS
BEING SERVED AND WHAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS AND OUR PROVIDERS ARE
PRODUCING THE BEST RESULTS AND
THE MOST YOU KNOW LABOR MARKET
ALIGNED RESULTS FOR THE
PARTICIPANTS THAT THEY'RE
SERVING. IN THOSE STATES THAT
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS I GUESS
MINNESOTA BEING ONE. WHERE THE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS ACTUALLY TAKE A ROLE IN
COLLECTING ADDITIONAL DATA
POINTS BEYOND THE BASE WAGE FILE.
HAVE YOU FOUND THAT THE BLOKE A
WORK DEVELOPMENT BOARDS ARE
ALREADY STAFFED FOR THIS SORT OF
THE DUTY OR- HAS IT REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
STATE TO. IMPLEMENT THIS
ADDITIONAL REPORTING. SO IT IS
CERTAINLY THE CASE THAT FUNDING
FOR DATA SYSTEMS ARE CHANGING
CHANGES TO EXISTING SYSTEMS CAN
BE FUNDAMENTAL FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL EXPANSION OF A DATA
ACCESS AND OUTCOMES REPORTING- I
THINK WHERE IT IS OFTEN SEEN IS
IN THE COMMUNICATION THAT IS
REALLY NEEDED WHETHER IT'S AT
THAT LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARD LEVEL
OR AGAIN THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WHOSE IMPLEMENTING
OR PARTICIPATING IN A STATE
FUNDED GRANT PROGRAM. SO THIS
THIS OFTEN- CAN TAKE THE
EMPHASIS OF STAFF TRAINING AND
ONGOING TECHNICAL SUPPORT WITH
WORK FORCE TRAINING PROVIDERS TO
HELP THEM UNDERSTAND WHAT THESE
NEW REQUIREMENTS WILL BE HOW
THIS DATA IS MEASURED AND USED
AND I WOULD ALSO ADD INSURING
THAT CUSTOMERS BEING SERVED TO
KNOW WHAT DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS ARE BEING
COLLECTED ABOUT THEM HOW THEIR
DATA ARE BEING USED TO MEASURE.
THEIR LONG TERM EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES SO IN SOME
CASES THERE MAY BE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AROUND- PRIVACY
DISCLOSURES THAT CUSTOMERS FIND
AS THEY PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WERE. REPORTING
THEM AND THEIR OUTCOMES IN A WAY
IN A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY AND
I ASSUME SINCE THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL DUTY THIS STATE
FUNDING WOULD BE REQUIRED IN
ORDER AND HAS BEEN RECORDED IN
THOSE STATES THAT HAVE DONE IT
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO HAPPEN
RIGHT. YES IT IS CERTAINLY
HELPFUL AGAIN TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES TO EXISTING SYSTEMS AND
TO SUPPORT YOU KNOW THAT
ADDITIONAL NEED FOR STAFF
TRAINING AND ONGOING TECHNICAL
SUPPORT AT LEAST IN AN INTERIM
BASIS. R. AS THESE EXPANDED
PERFORMANCE MEASURES ARE BEING
FUNDED I WOULD ALSO SAY TO THE
DEGREE THAT THESE. TOOLS ARE
BEING MADE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
FUNDING OR SUPPORT TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR UPDATED ROUTINELY AND
THAT INFORMATION IS ACCESSIBLE
TO A WIDE PUBLIC AUDIENCE. AND
BEING- SHARED AND COMMUNICATED
WITH YOU KNOW LEGISLATORS AND
OTHER SKILLED ADVOCATES WITHIN
THE STATE IT CERTAINLY OUGHT ONE
CONSIDERATION AS WELL. AND I
WONDER IF YOU COULD ENLIGHTEN US
AS TO. WHAT IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES AND POTENTIAL COSTS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN IN THE STATES THAT
HAVE ATTEMPTED THIS ENHANCED
LABOR MARKET REPORT INFORMATION
REPORTING. YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY
THIS IS WHERE STATES HAVE ALSO
TAKEN OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH OUR
PARTICIPATION WITH NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE NATIONAL
SKILLS COALITION OF WHO WHO
REALLY AND WE DO WORK WITH
STATES THROUGH POLICY ACADEMIES
TO ADVANCE THIS WORK SO IT IS
ALSO TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
OTHER OFF FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT MIGHT EXIST TO SUPPORT.
THIS THIS EXPANDED AT WORK DATA
REPORTING AND DATA COLLECTION AS
WELL SO THAT HAS BEEN ANOTHER
RESOURCE THAT STATES HAVE LOOKED
TOWARDS TO SUPPLEMENT AND
SUPPORT THIS WORK WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW FEDERAL OF FUNDING
GRANTS THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
TO EXPAND IN A WORK FORCE IN
EDUCATION DATA LINKAGES AUSTIN
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEMS OR
THROUGH THE SUPPORT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OF NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO CAN PROVIDE.
RESOURCES AND FEEDBACK ON HOW TO
DO THIS AND IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY AND IN OTHER STATES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY DOING THIS
SOME OF THE PROCESS THE ENHANCED
PROCESS HE'S BEEN GOING ON LONG
ENOUGH SO THAT REPORTS HAVE BEEN
GENERATED SO SOMEONE LIKE ME
COULD PULL A REPORT FROM THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON OR SOME
OTHER STATE TO ACTUALLY SEE THE
IMPACT OF HAVING ENHANCED DATA.
ON MEASURING THE EFFECTIVENESS
SON OF CAREER TECH EDUCATION
PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE. SURE THERE
ARE CERTAINLY SOME STATES WHO
HAVE- YOU KNOW SEVERAL YEARS
WORTH OF DATA I GO BACK TO THE
MINNESOTA EXAMPLE MINNESOTA
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN HAS MADE
AVAILABLE THIS INFORMATION SO
LONGITUDINALLY- THE STATE
AGENCY- AND LEGISLATORS CAN LOOK
AT. HOW VARIOUS PROGRAMS ARE ARE
REALLY IMPACTING AND INFLUENCING
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE GOALS
PARTICULARLY AROUND EQUITY.
THERE ARE OTHER STATES WHO ARE
JUST BEGINNING THIS WORK AD
THERE WAS A PANELIST EARLIER WHO
REFERENCE TO THE ELIGIBLE
TRAINING PROVIDER LIST WHICH IS
USED BY WYO WAY PARTICIPANTS
OUGHT TO SELECT TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING FUNDED.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF WORK WITH
STATES OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A
HALF THAT ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON.
ADVANCING THE QUALITY AND EQUITY
IN THEIR STATES ELIGIBLE
TRAINING PROVIDER LIST AND SO
WE'LL START SEEING THE BENEFITS
OF SOME OF THOSE STATES COME TO
FRUITION. IN THE NEXT YEAR. AND
WITH RESPECT TO THE IMPACT ON
TRAINING PROGRAMS ONCE THE
ACTUALLY THE ENHANCED DATA WAS
AVAILABLE AND- ANALYSED WHAT
IMPACT ON THE ON THE ACTUAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT WERE IN.
PLACE AT THE TIME. OCCURRED IF
YOU CAN TALK IF YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THAT. SO I'LL GO BACK TO THE
EXAMPLE OF STATES WHO ARE REALLY
LOOKING. AT THIS DATA THROUGH
THEIR ELIGIBLE TRAINING PROVIDER
LISTS WE ARE SEEN STATES IN NEW
JERSEY IS A RECET EXAMPLE WHO
WILL REALLY BE EVALUATING
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR WYO A FUNDING TO
TRAIN. OUR TITLE ONE INDIVIDUALS
AND THEY'RE REALLY GOING TO BE
STARTING TO REMOVE OUR TRAINING
PROVIDERS WHO DON'T MEET THE
QUALITY ASSURANCE STANDARDS THAT
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED. WHICH
ALSO INCLUDE- DISAGGREGATION OF
DATA BY RACE ETHNICITY AND OTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS AND
SO- THAT'S CERTAINLY IS ONE
OPPORTUNITY THAT STATES ARE
TAKING TO- SAY THAT YOU KNOW
TRAINING PROGRAMS WON'T RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUNDING ANY LONGER TO
SERVE CUSTOMERS IF THEIR
OUTCOMES. ARE A BELOW A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD. BUT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE YET MAYBE IN MINNESOTA.
TO SEE WHAT PROGRAMMATIC SAVINGS
RESULTED FROM THE AVAILABILITY
AND USE OF THIS ENHANCED DATA
REPORTING TO ACTUALLY TRY TO
MAKE THE LINES CROSS BETWEEN JOB
TRAINING AND- JOBS THAT- WERE
SECURED- I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
SORT OF DATA IS AVAILABLE IN THE
REPORTING BUT IF NOT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING IT WHEN IT IS.
IN THE- DISH AT EVERY TURN ON
INVESTMENT DATA WOULD CERTAINLY
BE RELEVANT HERE AND I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW THERE ARE STATES WHO
ARE ADVANCING- THE WORK ON
EVALUATING WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS MINNESOTA ALSO HAPPENS
TO BE ONE OF THOSE STATES. ARE
REALLY USING AND LEVERAGING
PROGRAM PARTICIPATION DATA
AGAINST COMPARISON GROUPS TO
SHOW WHAT THE IMPACT AND WHAT
ACTUALLY IS THE PUBLIC- BENEFITS
AND RETURN ON INVESTMENT OF
TRAINING PROGRAMS IN THE LONG
TERM. EXCELLENT VERY
ENLIGHTENING THAT I FAILED TO
ASK SOMETHING THAT I SHOULD HAVE
THEM. YOU DIDN'T THIS IS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN FOR
TAKING YOUR TIME. OUR NEXT
PANELIST DISMISSED STEVE SAXTON
CONSULTANT TO T. THREE
INNOVATION NETWORK. THERE WE GO
GOOD AFTERNOON THERE YOU ARE
THANK YOU SIR FOR JOINING US
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME. WELL AS
YOU'VE CERTAINLY HEARD TODAY
THERE'S LOTS OF INTERESTING
AMOUNT BETTER INFORMATION
YOURSELF CENTER OF EXPRESS THAT
DESIRE TO HELP. MUCH MORE IN
DEPTH INFORMATION. FOR WORKFORCE
PURPOSES. BARBARA BUT- TWO
MINUTES EARLY TO DISCUSS A STEP
FROM THAT AND TALK ABOUT JUST
HOW BROAD THE INTEREST GOES IN
THIS KIND OF INFORMATION.
CERTAINLY ALL STATES ARE
INTERESTED IN AND BETTER
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR TRAINING
PARTICIPANTS BUT- MR MILLER
SHARE US SURE SOME FLOODS HERE A
KIND OF LEAD YOU. MAYBE FROM THE
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL BACK
DOWN INTO WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT MADE NUMEROUS. THERE WE GO
OKAY GOOD OUT HERE. FIRST IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE IN THE
LIGHTWEIGHT RECORDS HELLO THE
CORE ELEMENTS NAME SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER AND TOTAL WAGES
THAT ARE REPORTED BY ALL FIFTY
THREE JURISDICTIONS THAT
OPERATED MEDICAL INSURANCE
PROGRAM. WHAT IS SUPPOSED TO
MENTION SOME STATES. ANOTHER
JURISDICTION TRAILS ONE OF THOSE
DATA. OVER MANY YEARS WASHINGTON
WHICH WILL BE THE FIRST STATE TO
DO THAT BACK IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES HOURS OF WORK
BACKGROUND. IT OVER TIME MORGAN
ADDED ALASKA IN OCCUPATION
AROUND THE BEGINNING OF THE
NINEEEN NINETIES. OVER WITH WE
CONTINUALLY THAT AND MORE AND
MORE AND DO NOT NECESSARILY NEED
ORGANIZED FOR ACTION. HELLO IT
IS GROWN IN FACT WOMEN STREET
NOW COLLECTS DATA- MONTHLY WAGE
RECORDS MONTHLY DATA MAKES
EXPRESSLY DID THAT TO PROVE THE
FLORIDA TEXAS A PURPOSE FOR
PROTECTION PURPOSES. LET'S
CONTINUE. IN ABOUT THE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN ORIGIN SHOULD
CALL THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
COUNSEL OR HAVE SERVED ON PRIOR
TO THAT. I DECIDED TO DO A STUDY
JUST WHAT THE POSSIBILITIES. FOR
ENHANCING WHAT DIRECTIONS. AND
SO WE LOOKED AT LIKE WE
CONSULTANT CROWD. WE LOOKED WE
TALKED TO EMPLOYERS WE TALKED TO%
HAD RULE SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
TALKED STRAIGHT YOU WIND UP
RATIONS WE TALKED TO GOVERNMENT
STATISTICAL AGENCIES. TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE POSSIBILITIES WERE
AND WHAT THE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES WERE. TO ENHANCING.
THOSE WAGE RECORD SO WE HAD
BETTER INFORMATION. YEAH COUPLE
NUMBER FOR ISSUE. THE FORTY TO
FIFTEEN THINGS I THINK PALE
MENTION ONE A LITTLE EARLIER
TODAY. HE TALKED ABOUT HOW SOME
OF THOSE DATA WERE WERE BEING
USED COULD BE USED. YEAH WE CAN
WE CAN ALL THE NUMBER
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND- COUPLE REPORTER
WANTS TO BE ANYWHERE AND WORK
ONE WE NEED BETTER COLLABORATION
IN DOING THAT SO THAT WE HELLO.
COMPARABLE INFORMATION ZERO
THERE'S AN INDIVIDUAL OR AN
INSTITUTION WANTS TO FOLLOW
TRAINING PROVIDERS. BUT IT WAS
STRIPPED OF PROTECTIONS WHAT
MANY PEOPLE DON'T STAY IN THE
LOCAL AREA EIGHT THREE WE WERE
ON THE STREET AT THE GULF STATES
WE STILL WANT TO KNOW ARE THE
ONES OF THE SAME INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR UNCLES. AND SO IF WE
DON'T COLLECT THE SAME
INFORMATION. IN THE SAME MANNER.
ROSS THE COUNTRY. BUT WE'RE NOT
BE ABLE TO DO FOR A SECOND LET.
AND THE OTHER PART OF THAT WAS
BUT THE STANDARDS. WE HAVE WE
STUDENTS- VERY STRONG OF
ENHANCEMENTS TO THEIR WAGE. BUT
THEY- THEY MIGHT CALL THE SORT
OF WITH THE IT DOES. EXAMPLE BE
ORDER I WANT BOTH COLLECT HOURS
WORKED ONE INCLUDES THE
CLEVELAND THEIR HOURS WORKED THE
OTHER DOES NOT INCLUDE STRICTLY
COME OUT. SO YOU CAN'T REALLY.
COMPARE THOSE TO DIRECTLY. SO
GENERALIZATION IN COLLABORATION.
ORGANIZATIONS WORK TOGETHER TO
DECIDE WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
HELD UP SHOULD WE- BUT WHAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING. WELL I
THINK IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
CAME OUT OF THAT STUFF-
FOLLOWING THAT WE MOSTLY
WORKFORCE INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY
ACT NEED A LITTLE MORE
PRECIPITATION COUNCIL WHERE- WAS
DISBANDED AND WE KNEW WHAT
WORKFORCE INFORMATION ADVISORY
COUNCIL WAS FORMED- IT WAS A
BROADER BASED ADVISORY COUNCIL
TO THE SECRETARY OF LABOR ABOUT.
THE WORKFORCE INFORMATION SYSTEM.
YEAH PLEASE A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO THEY WERE FOUNDED IN. TWO
THOUSAND SO X. MEDICAL AGO
CONDITION THE SECRETARY BUT
FIRST RECOMMENDATION I MADE WAS.
ENHANCE THE WAY DIRECTIVES.
CONTINUE THEIR CONTINUED TO
FOLLOW UP ON THOSE RECOGNITIONS.
THE SAME TIME IF THAT HAPPENS
HELLO THE U. S. CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE FOUNDATION. INITIATED
ANY OF THE T. THREE INNOVATION
NETWORK QUESTION. ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS. THE AND
WE WORK WITH THE PICTURE OPEN
STANDARDS CONSORTIUM TO. LOOK AT
HOW THE TALENT MARKETPLACE COULD
BE IMPROVED. NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THROUGH BETTER COLLABORATION.
ONE OF THEIR PROJECTS- LOOK AT
ALL ASPECTS OF THE TELEMARK ONE
ASPECT WAS WAS THE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE AT. I WAS PART OF
THE PROJECT TEAM THAT WORKED ON
INCLUDED EARNINGS DATA TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND OF DATA ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S
AVAILABLE WHAT'S NEEDED WHO'S
WHO NEEDS. WHICH KINDS OF DATA.
FINALLY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHICH
MORE LATER A LOT OUT OF THAT.
THE THREE ANIMATION AT WORK
PROJECT A NEW INITIATIVE HAS
BEEN STARTED BY THE US CHAMBER
FOUNDATION WHICH IS CALLED
JACKSON JOBS EMPLOYMENT DATA
EXCHANGE WHAT'S GOING TO BE SOME
UPCOMING EVENTS THAT I THINK
THIS GROUP MIGHT BE INTERESTED
IN. BASED ON THE- JUNE FIRST. WE
TO. A HIGH LEVEL DO ALL THE DATA
WE COULD FIND OUT WHO WANTS TO
IMPLEMENT AN EARNINGS DATA THIS
IS THIS IS A SUBSAMPLE OF SOME
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS ARE ASKING
FOR EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS DATA.
SO THERE'S- ALMOST FIFTY. RIGHT
HERE INCLUDES DOWN HERE ON THE
RIGHT HAND SIDE OF THE COIN
INSURANCE MONTHLY. AND QUARTERLY
REPORTS AND NATIONAL DIRECTORY
OF NEW HIRES BOTH OF THOSE ARE
OPERATED BY THOSE FIFTY THREE
JURISDICTIONS. NEW LIFE PROGRAMS.
A LITTLE BIT. WE FOUND OVER TWO
HUNDRED. VERY ABEL'S THERE
COLLECTED UNEMPLOYMENT AND
EARNINGS. AND WE WORK WITH THE-
UP HR OPEN STANDARDS CONSORTIUM
WHICH IS A CONSORTIUM OF. ALL
PROVIDERS EHR SOFTWARE PROVIDERS
THAT WORK TOGETHER TO SET
STANDARDS ON PARTICULAR THERE
EXCHANGING WHAT THEY HAVE TO
EXCHANGE DATA ON. REAL TIME
BASIS BECAUSE ONE- SOFTWARE
PROVIDER MAY DO THE TABLE.
MODULE THAT FORD EXPLORER
ANOTHER COMPANY MAY DO THE OTHER
H. R. MODULE. AND THOSE MODULES
HAVE TO COMMUNICATE WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH COMPLEX CHANGE DATA ON
A REAL TIME BASIS. SO THEY HAVE
STANDARDS IN TERMS OF WHAT WHAT
IT MEANS ASK FOR PARTICULAR
pGOING TO GET EXACTLY WHAT THEY
THINK THEY'RE GOING. TO GET. SO
WE TOOK ALL THAT INFORMATION
OFFICER. IN LOOKING. THIS IS
ACTUALLY FROM A MORE RECENT
STUDY. THIS ACTUALLY LOOKS AT
WHAT. EARLIER WAS MENTIONED SOME
OF THINGS OTHER STATES WERE
DOING. I JUST FINISHED AN
INVENTORY FOR A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION. HELLO ALL FIFTY
THREE JURISDICTIONS THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF DATA THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF DATA ELEMENTS THAT ARE
BEING COLLECTED RIGHT NOW ON
YOUR WAY SO THERE'S INSTRUCTIONS
ON ONE ORGANIZATION HAS THE
EMPLOYEE'S ADDRESS. NO THE DRIP
GOOD WRITTEN STREET NUMBER. CITY
STATE. ZIP CODE IS THE FOUR
VARIABLES HELLO BUT THERE'S A
WHOLE NUMBER OF VARIABLES THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH COMPENSATION
DEMOGRAPHICS. RACIAL
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION LIKE.
THE BILLING SERVER IS WORKING ON
A RECENT. PAID TIME. OR WE CAN
BE REIMBURSED FOR. HOW MUCH
MONEY IS BEING WITH HILL VARIOUS
KINDS OF THINGS ABOUT
COMPENSATION. I COULD TALK MORE
ABOUT- ALMOST. WHAT WE SAW WHEN
WE DID WITH THIS YOU HAVE ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED DIFFERENT REPORTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY GOT THE FIFTY
THREE YOU ARE GORGEOUS FIFTY
THREE YOU ARE OUR RECORDS AND A
WHOLE SLEW OF FEDERAL. DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEMS THE MINISTRY
OKAY AND STATISTICAL. WE'VE GOT
A TREMENDOUS VARIATION IN A
WHOLE BUNCH OF REPORTS AS THAT
NUMBER GROWS IS THE VOLUME OF
THE CUBE IT WALL STREET'S. THE
WORKLOAD THE COST FOR THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY GROWS
GEOMETRICALLY. YEAH SO WHAT WE
WERE TRUCK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE PULL-THIS BACK IN A LITTLE BIT HOW
CAN WE REDUCE SOME OF THAT
RADIATION WHICH NUMBER OF PORTS.
SO THAT. WE CAN GET MORE BANG
FOR THE BUCK. WHICH PULLS DATA-
HELLO WORKING WITH THE CHIEF
DATA ARCHITECT FROM EATING PIZZA
LARGE MINERAL PROCESSING FIRM.
WELL WE GOT THIS HIGH LEVEL
CONCEPTUAL MODEL WHICH COULD
DISH DESCRIBES DISPLAYS THE
TYPES OF INFORMATION. THAT ARE
BEING COLLECTED NOW AND HOW
THEY'RE STORED IN EMPLOYER
SYSTEM SO- LEFTY EITHER H. R.
SYSTEM. WE'LL LET YOU SEE THE
TIME LABOR SYSTEM WILL SYSTEM
UNTIL YOU HELD THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ORGANIZATION'S MISSION GOT JOBS
PHYSICIANS IN. ESTABLISHMENTS
THAT THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
FEDERAL. IMMIGRATION INFORMATION
ABOUT PEOPLE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THE WORLD A WORKER IN A
RELATIONSHIP. WITH THAT WORKER
HAS WITH THE ORGANIZATION. THE
WORK IS. HELLO COMING OUT OF ALL
THAT YOUR MOTHER TOOK THE TIME
THAT THEY PUT IT ON. HOW MUCH
THEY'RE COMPENSATED FOR THAT
TIME PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THAT
MAY WORK AGAINST. HERE'S WE
CREATED A DATA DICTIONARY THAT
INSURE BECAUSE OF STRANGERS
CONSORTIUM HAS ADOPTED THEIR
MEMBERSHIP. REVIEW THAT AND
ISN'T A DOCTOR THE DATA
DICTIONARY SO THAT THEY HAVE A
STANDARDIZED SET OF. DEFINITIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE VARIABLES
THAT WERE WERE COLLECTING. YOU
CAN SEE CATEGORIES OF
INFORMATION ACCORDING TO THE
DICTIONARY AND I WATCHED IT
FALLS WITHIN THE DATA DICTIONARY.
EARLIER WAS NOT. QUESTION WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT'S RIGHT THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
CAPTURED IN THIS DATABASE THERE
ARE FOUR TYPES OF WORKERS THAT
ARE CAPTURED IN THIS DATABASE.
TRADITIONAL EMPLOYEES
CONTRACTORS INTERIM POLICE OR
THIRD PARTY LAWYERS AND THEN
VOLUNTEERS SO THERE'S YOU CAN
ISOLATE INFORMATION ABOUT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THIS THE
STATEMENTS. EXAMPLES OF WHAT'S
IN THERE FOR THE ORGANIZATION
FOR EXAMPLE YOU CAN SEE. THE
NUMBER OF. FROM EXPECTED THINGS
TO TELL TELL YOU ABOUT THE FIRM.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT PAID
TIME BECAUSE TOTAL HOURS PAID
WHICH IS COMPRISED OF TOTAL
HOURS WORKED IN TOTAL HOURS OF
PAID TIME OFF. YOU ALSO HAVE A
WEEK'S WORK AND WHETHER OR NOT
AN INDIVIDUAL WORKS THE PAPER
INCLUDES THE TWELFTH OF THE
MONTH WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO A
LOT OF STATISTICAL SECTION.
TOTAL COMPENSATION MADE UP OF
TOTAL CASH TOTAL NON CASH
COMPENSATION IS IN CASH. SORRY
WHICH IS A RELIGION'S LEAVE PAID
OTHER CASH COMPENSATION LIKE
COMMISSIONS. OR BONUSES OR PEACE
WORKER. THIS IS THIS IS A HIGH
LEVEL THERE'S MANY MANY
VARIABLES WITHIN EACH ONE OF
THESE THINGS. WE THOUGHT SORT OF
THINKING ABOUT HOW HOW WE'RE
DOING THIS NOW IN THIS GROUP WE
HAVE. A LOT OF THE COLLECTION
THAT KIND OF REFLECTS WHAT YOU
SEE ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THIS.
ALL WE'RE LEFT BUT CERTAINLY NOT
ALL NOT TOWARDS THE RIGHT. OUR
BELIEF IS THAT THE FARTHER YOU
GO TO WAR RIGHT. THE LOWER YOUR
COSTS LOWER MARGINAL COSTS IS
GOING TO BE A HIGHER VALUE. SO
WE WORK TOGETHER WE- YOU CAN
FIND WAYS OF COLLECTING DATA.
ANSWER MULTIPLE PURPOSES. WE CAN
GET POPULATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE
BETTER DATA. AT A LOWER OVERALL
COST. THIS IS A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH YEAH RIGHT IT RESIDUAL
ONE BETTER DATA WE'RE GETTING.
DATA DATA PORTS HEALTH DATA NOT
MANY THAT'S WHERE THEIR
BUSINESSES THE REPORTING IT TO
VARIOUS DIFFERENT GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES RECORDING IT WAY TOO
MUCH- BUT THEY HAVE THE DATA
ALEX JUST COST THEM A LOT AND IS
ONE THING TO TRY OUT. EARLY
STUDYING TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WAS TALKING TO
THE. NATIONAL PAYROLL RECORDED
CONSORTIUM. OUR THIS IS THE
BIGGEST STUMBLING BLOCK
EMPLOYERS THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE VOLUME OF DATA
THAT THEY HAVE TO REPORT IT'S
THE VARIATION SO BECAUSE THERE
ARE FIFTY THREE DIFFERENT. YOU
ARE SYSTEMS IN NEW HIRE SYSTEMS
ON SIXTY RAINY FEDERAL SYSTEMS.
THEY HAVE TO CUSTOMIZE THE
COURTS EVERY TIME THEY LOOK MORE.
THAT HAS TO COST. SO THEY WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO FIND A WAY TO
STANDARDIZE CENTRALIZE AGREE CAN.
THE DATA COLLECTION. QUICKLY
HELLO THIRTEEN COSTS- HELLO
TRYING TO IMPROVE THE YES THE
SYSTEM FOR THIS WORK. PARTNERS
OR STAKEHOLDERS. BUT THERE IS A
VARIETY OF REPORTS THAT ARE OUT
THERE FROM VARIOUS STUDIES THAT
IF ANYBODY'S INTERESTED. WE HAVE
A DENTURE ALL THIS INFORMATION
SO. WITH THAT I'M GONNA DROP
THIS OFF BUT CERTAINLY HASN'T
QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK ABOUT
ANY OF US. HELLO WHERE ARE WE
WITH THIS I MEAN I ASSUME THIS
IS AN IMPLEMENTATION ISSUE WELL
THAT'S VERY GOOD QUESTION HELLO.
THE REPORT CAME OUT OF THE- TWO
THREE NETWORK CAME OUT IN
FEBRUARY FOLLOWING THAT DO YOU.
WE MUST CHAMBER FOUNDATION- A
DECISION TO INITIATE THIS JEFF
EXPONENTIALLY JOHNSON QUOTED
EXCHANGE- WHICH FORMED A- FIVE
THREE COMMITTEE. MANY NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED INDIVIDUALS ABOUT
FORTY PEOPLE TO RISE HOW TO HOW
TO PROCEED. NOT OF THAT CHAMBER
RECOMMENDATION REPORT. THAT
SHOULD OPERATE TWO DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS THE TRUTH THIS IS
POSSIBLE. AND SO IN THE AREA OF
THIS. WINTERTON HAS LEARNED TO
JUST IMPLEMENT EARNINGS DATA-
THERE WILL BE A DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT WILL BEGIN. EUROPE THREE
MONTHS- STATES HAVE BEEN ASKED
FOR THEIR INTEREST IN
PARTICIPATING. IRAN DOES
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT WORK HELLO
THE JOINT PARTICIPATION OF
STATES FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
FEDERAL PROCESSING SOFTWARE
INDUSTRY EMPLOYER ORGANIZATIONS
TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON WHAT
SHOULD BE COLLECTED AND HOW
SHOULD BE COLLECTED. AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THE OWNERSHIP WAS
ANOTHER GROUP THAT YOU'LL BE
TALKING. WHAT ABOUT WHAT'S THE
MOST EFFICIENT TECHNOLOGICAL
WAYS TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
SOMEONE SHE WOULD PAY ROLL
INDUSTRY. I WAS PRETTY EFFICIENT
WAYS OF EXCHANGING INFORMATION
QUICKLY. THEY WILL BE INVOLVED
HIM TRYING TO COME UP WITH THE
BEST TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS TO
THIS WE CAN LOWER THE- COST OF
DELIVERING INFORMATION SHARING
INFORMATION AND THE SAME TIME.
HENCE THE TYPES OF INFORMATION
BETTER PROGRAM. WELL I'M JUST
CURIOUS IS DID CALIFORNIA
INDICATED INTEREST IN
PARTICIPATING WITH YOU IN THIS
PILOT PROGRAM. WELL IT THE
CHAMBER IS GOING TO ANNOUNCE
THE- STATES WHO HELD. EXPRESSED
AN INTEREST VERY SHORTLY HERE
NEXT WEEK OR TWO THERE WILL BE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT COMING ON I
DON'T I DON'T WANT TO JUMP THE
GUN ON THEIR HOUSE. BUT IT COULD
KILL FORTY WANTS TO. PRESENT IT
THE NUMBERS OF CALIFORNIA. THE
COMPANY. THINKS ABOUT. TO THE
BUT WELL WE'LL WAIT FOR THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT BUT I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUES AND I'LL HAVE SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES IT'LL BE INTERESTED
IN HEARING THE ANSWERS SO WE'LL
WE'LL STAY TUNED. IT'S I THINK
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITIES THERE
ARE. I THINK WE HAVE SEPARATE
STATES. THROUGH IT RIGHT NOW BUT
WE'RE WILLING TO SIT DOWN AND
TALK ABOUT HOW HOW TO GO ABOUT
DOING THIS. YEAH LIKE I SAID WE
GOT THOSE WE'VE GOT FEDERAL
AGENCIES THAT ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN DOING THIS. FOLLOW
ME ON THE COMPUTER COMMUNITY
THIS IS HOW IT IS INDICATED BY
THE FACT THAT US CHAMBERS.
FOUNDATION. IS BEHIND US. VERY
INTERESTED IN FINDING WAYS TO
GET BETTER- WORKFORCE ANALYTICS.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING SOME OF
THAT IN. WHAT IS IT LIKE A DEEP
CREEK LAKE THE SERVER HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF- BOOK EXPLORERS
AND ONE IN THE COUNTRY WELL
THEY'RE STARTING TO GENERATE
THEIR OWN. STATISTICAL
INFORMATION BASED ON JUST WHAT
THEY HAVE SO THAT EVERY MONTH
I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN WHAT THEY
PUT OUT THEIR OWN JOBS REPORT A
FEW DAYS BEFORE YOUR LIKES
DISLIKES. THEY'RE THEY'RE
COLLECTING AND BEGINNING TO
GENERATE WORKFORCE ANALYTICS
BASED ON JUST WHAT THEY. HAVE ON
IT AND THEY'D LOVE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO. ALL THE OTHER FIRMS
DATED SO QUICKLY FIND WHAT. ALL
THAT. THE IT WILL IT WILL BE A
VERY RICH SOURCE. OF COURSE THIS
IS YOU KNOW I USED I SAY BY THE
ENTRANCE TO SENSE BY THE YARD
IT'S HARD OF COURSE. COMING TO
SOME AGREEMENT ON THE STRUCTURE
IS- HALF THE BATTLE OF COURSE.
I'M SURE THE OTHER. PIECE OF
THIS WILL BE FUNDING THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. BUT
IMPROVEMENTS NECESSARY TO. HAVE
A SYSTEM THAT WORKS ACROSS STATE
LINES AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
FOUNDRIES AS WELL SO I GUESS
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW THIS WORKS
OUT BUT- IT SOUNDS PROMISING AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO.
STEVE ON THIS MATTER ANYTHING
ELSE. PRECIADO VERY MUCH YOU
TAKING THE TIME TO BE WITH US
AND YOUR EFFORT IN TRYING TO.
BRING ABOUT SOME ORDER TO WHAT
APPEARS TO BE. A STATE OF
DISORDER AT LEAST WITH TWO
HUNDRED REPORTS IN A VARIETY OF
OTHER THINGS AT THEM. WE NEED TO
SOMEHOW GET ORGANIZED SO WE GET
THE USEFUL DATA THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO EVALUATE THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS- AND FOR OTHER REASONS-
IN THIS FIELD SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR. ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
POINTS THEY MENTIONED THE
INVENTORY OF STATE YOU ARE A
SYSTEM THAT THAT REPORT SHOULD
BE COMING OUT FROM THE- LABOR
MARKET INFORMATION WAS JUNE-
HERE IN THE- NEXT FEW WEEKS AS
WELL. NOT JUST ONE NO MORE SO
THE NUMBERS FOR YOU. RIGHT NOW
ALL. YOU LOOK AT THE NON CORE
DATA LEMENTS. THIRTY EIGHT
STATES FOR COLLECTING SEVENTY
FOUR DIFFERENT. DATA ELEMENTS
ALL YOUR DRIVES. SO IT'S A IT'S
A PRETTY EXTENSIVE- CANCEL IT
ALREADY HAPPENED BUT AGAIN IT'S
VERY FOREIGN LANGUAGE THE
FOLLOWING VERY INCONSISTENT. AND
WE'RE NOT SO WE NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR APPRECIATE YOUR
HELP WHAT OUR NEXT PANELIST
DESERVES TO TELL MEN WAECHTER
PRESS PROFESSOR OF ECONOMICS
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES DIRECTOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY.
WE THANK THANK YOU SOUND THE
ROUGH WEATHER INVITATION TO
TESTIFY TODAY SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS I'M ABOUT TO MAKE HAVE
COME UP- SO I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF
AND I SHOULD SAY MY- THIRD CHILD
IS A COUPLE OF WEEKS OLD- SO I
HAVE SOME NOTES TO KEEP ME ON
TRACK- LET ME START WITH THE
BOTTOM LINES. ENHANCING THAT YOU
I. BASE WAGE FILED THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SPACE
WHICH FILE. I COLLECTING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SUCH AS
OCCUPATION. HOURS AND WEEKS WORK
THE LOCATION OF WORK AND BASIC-DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS.
IT'S VERY CLEAR BENEFITS FOR
WORKERS. EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA
AS A WHOLE. AND THE CHANGES
BROUGHT BY DURING THE PANDEMIC
AN ONGOING TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE
LED THE EFFORT TO ENHANCE THE
WHITE BASS REG FILE SOME
URGENCY. AND THE GOOD NEWS I
THINK IS THAT OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THIS
IS POSSIBLE. I HAVE PROVIDED
INFORMATION ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD. OUT FOR DECADES YOU I
BASICALLY FIND HAVE BEEN THE
BACKBONE OF ANY EVALUATION OF
TRAINING AND EDUCATION PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES AND THESE DATA PROVIDE
INVALUABLE AND TIMELY
INFORMATION ON QUARTERLY
EMPLOYMENT AND EARNINGS THAT
ALLOW REALLY DETAILED INSIGHTS
FOR ALL EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUCH COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION WOULD NEARLY BE
IMPOSSIBLE TO OBTAIN THE OTHER
DATA SOURCES. HOWEVER YOU KNOW
AS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
CURRENT ELEMENTS ARE VERY COARSE
AND IMPOSE SUBSTANTIAL
IMITATIONS WHAT WE CAN LEARN TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE FOR EACH
EMPLOYEE THE BASS REG FILES
CURRENTLY CONTAIN ONLY TOTAL
QUARTERLY EARNINGS. AT EACH
EMPLOYER. THIS IS PARTLY BECAUSE
THE EXISTING BASE WHICH FILE IS
A PRODUCT OF THE NINETEEN
NINETIES. SO THE GOOD NEWS HERE
IS THAT THE AVAILABLE DATA
REALLY GIVES THE IDEAL
FOUNDATION ON WHICH TO BUILD A
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT RISES
TO THE CHALLENGES OF OUR TIME.
AND I'M GONNA GO GOING TO FOCUS
ON FOR DATA ELEMENTS. THAT WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY ENHANCE THE WHITE
BASE WHICH FILE AND WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH THAT. PERSON TO PATIENT
THE SECOND IS HOURS AND WEEKS
WORK THE THIRTIES PLACE OF WORK.
AND THE FOURTH IS BASIC WORKER
DEMOGRAPHICS. THESE FOUR
ELEMENTS. HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
COLLECTED AT MANAGEABLE COSTS IN
OTHER STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES
AND THEY WOULD REALLY HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS EMPLOYERS
AND THE STATE OF THE WHOLE RIGHT
THEY WOULD FURTHER IMPROVE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPACT FOR
TRAINING AND EDUCATION SYSTEM.
DID THEY WERE ALLOWED TO BETTER
TRACK DEVELOPING OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AS A WHOLE
BUT ALSO DOWN TO THE FINE
GRAINED LOCAL LEVEL. AND THEY
WOULD ALLOW US TO BETTER MEASURE
THE EFFECTS OF KEY REGULATIONS
IN THE LABOR MARKET SUCH AS THAT
MINIMUM WAGE. AND THEY WOULD
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO FURTHER
IMPROVE ITS SERVICES FOR THE
UNEMPLOYED. I WILL GIVE YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THESE PROPOSED
FOR DATA ELEMENTS. FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF AN EXPERT. IN
LABOR ECONOMICS I I'VE SPENT
OVER TWENTY YEARS DOING
RESEARCH. AND GIVING POLICY
ADVICE BASED ON ADMINISTRATIVE
RUNNING STAFF IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE U. S. AND FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES. AND ASKED HIM KIND
MEANT KINDLY MENTIONED. AT THE
OUTSET I ALSO KOHLI DEVALUATION
OF THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
PARTICIPATING. IN THE CALCULUS
STUDENT FOR STRUCTURE. NOW
DECADES OF RESEARCH VERY CLEARLY
TO THE NEED TO ADD THE FOUR DATA
ELEMENTS I MENTIONED TO THE BASE
WAGE FILES AND I BELIEVE THE
CASE FOR ADDING EACH OF THESE
DATA ELEMENTS IS ACTUALLY VERY
STRONG NOW CONSIDER FIRST THE
CASE FOR MEASURING HOURS AND
WEEKS WORKED AS WELL AS A NEW
PATIENT. MEASURING HOURS. WEEKLY
HOURS WORKED WOULD ALLOW ONE TO
INFER THE EFFECTIVE HOURLY WAGE
RATE FOR EACH WORKER. THAT'S
CRUCIAL BECAUSE HOURLY WAGES ARE
ROUTINELY USED BY CONDOMS TO
MEASURE HOW PRODUCTIVE WORKERS
ARE AND WHAT A GOOD JOB AS- AS A
RESULT ALI WAGES ARE USING
EMPIRICAL WORK ALL OVER THE
WORLD AND IN MANY DISCIPLINES.
TO MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS. IN A SIMILAR FASHION
OCCUPATION IT IS A KEY INPUT AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
ARE SUCCESSFUL AT PLACING
WORKERS INTO BETTER JOBS IT
RAISING LIVING STANDARDS AND A
GENERATING A HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE
WORKFORCE. HELP WITHOUT
INFORMATION ON HOURS AND A FEW
PATIENTS IT IS MORE DIFFICULT TO
FULLY EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF OUR EDUCATION AND TRAINING
SYSTEM. BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THEIR DRESS ADDRESSES THE
MANY CHALLENGES OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT THE CHANGING NATURE OF WORK.
AMONG OTHERS. OF COURSE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND THE MANY AGENCIES
PROVIDING EDUCATION AND TRAINING
IN CALIFORNIA WORK VERY HARD
EVERY DAY TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
AND THE EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS
TRAINING SERVICES AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. THE POINT
HERE IS THAT INFORMATION HOURS
OKAY PATIENT. AS WELL AS THE
OTHER DATA MANAGEMENT THAT I
MENTIONED WOULD REALLY HELP.
WITH THAT PROCESS RIGHT WITH
THESE DATA WE CAN FIGURE OUT
WHICH EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS. ACTUALLY IMPROVE JOB
QUALITY. WE CAN FIGURE OUT
WHETHER SOME PROGRAMS WORK
BETTER FOR SOME INDIVIDUALS AND
OTHERS. EITHER BY DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS ARE BY. LOCAL ECONOMIES
AND WE CAN THEN USE THIS
INFORMATION TO BETTER TARGET
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
ACROSS THEM A GRAPHIC GROUPS AND
LOCAL LABOR MARKETS. HOURS
WORKED AND OCCUPATION ALSO
GREATLY HELPED ENHANCE THE VALUE
OF EXISTING. DATA INVESTMENT
THAT REALLY HAVE IMPROVED WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR MARKETS YOU'RE SUCH A
SNACK. CAL SKILLS DATA FOR THE
CROWN TO CAREER DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE. I BELIEVE WE
TURN TO THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
TWO OTHER DATA ELEMENTS I
MENTIONED WHICH IS LOCATION OF
WORKS AND DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS. AS SENATOR ROTH
HAS HELPED TO ZOOM IN ON QUITE
BITTER POLITICALLY FOR SOME OF
US IS THAT SUCH INFORMATION
INFORMATION ON PLACE OF WORK.
WOULD ALLOW US TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHICH EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
LOCALLY. AS THE LABOR MARKET IS
CHANGING AT THE END OF THE
PANDEMIC IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND DIFFERENCES BY
LOCAL LABOR MARKET AND BY
DEMOGRAPHIC RECORDS.
CHARACTERISTICS WHAT WE
CURRENTLY KNOW. COMMUNITIES WITH
MORE BLACK RESIDENTS MORE
HISPANIC RESIDENT RESIDENTS AND
POOR NEIGHBORHOODS. HAVE BEEN
MORE STRONGLY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND HAVE RECOVERED MORE
SLOWLY. BUT WE COULD KNOW MUCH
MUCH MORE ABOUT HOW THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE IMPACTED AND HOW
TO HELP THEM. YEAH IN ADDITION
YOU KNOW WITHIN VOTE INVOLVING
CLIMATE. IT WOULD BECOME
INCREASINGLY URGENT TO
UNDERSTAND THE LOCAL IMPACT. OF
NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES. IT IS CURRENTLY NOT
POSSIBLE IN THE BASE WHICH FILE.
AT LEAST FOR THE MANY EMPLOYERS
WITH WITH MULTIPLE JOB SITES.
NOW TO GATHER THESE FOUR DATA
ELEMENTS BESIDES IMPROVING OUR
PROVISION OF EDUCATION AND
TRAINING AND BESIDES TRACKING.
HOW THE ECONOMY'S DOING RIGHT.
AT THE CALIFORNIA LEVELED ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL OF MY DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS RIGHT. IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
BETTER UNDERSTANDING HOW LABOR
MARKET REGULATIONS AFFECT
WORKERS BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
LABOR MARKET WE'RE GONNA GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE. WHEN WE
EVALUATED THE MINIMUM WAGE
ORDINANCE OF THE CITY OF LA. THE
ABSENCE OF DATA ON OURS. RIGHT
WAS AN IMPORTANT LIMITATION. AS
A RESULT WE COULD NOT FIGURE OUT
WHICH BUSINESS IS ACTUALLY WE'RE
EMPLOYING WORKERS AFFECTED BY
THE MINIMUM WAGE. THAT WAS A
REAL LOSS NOW OF COURSE WE WANT
TO SEE WHICH WORKERS ACTUALLY
BENEFITED BY THE MINIMUM WAGE
WHICH WE COULD NOT. WILLING
RIGHT WE ALSO WANTED TO SEE
WHICH SMALLER BUSINESSES MIGHT
BE STRUGGLING. AND WHICH SMALLER
BUSINESSES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
BECAUSE OF INCREASES IN WAGES
COULD BENEFIT FROM TARGETED
PROGRAMS FOR SMALL BUSINESS
DISTRICT THE COUNTY AND CITY
MADE AVAILABLE. TO YOU KNOW
BUSINESS AFFECTED BY THE MINIMUM
WAGE SO THERE WAS A REAL LOSS IN
AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OUR
REGULATIONS AFFECT THE LABOR
MARKET WORKERS BUSINESSES RIGHT
BECAUSE OF AN ABSENCE. OF DATA
ON HOURS WORKED. AND LAST AND
DEFINITELY NOT LEAST AND WE'VE
ALREADY DISCUSSED IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND
ENHANCING THAT BASE WAGE FIGHT.
WILL ALSO HELP TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICES THAT CALIFORNIA
PROVIDES. TO ITS UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS BEGAN. TO DISH ALL DATA
ELEMENTS WOULD ALLOW IT TO
BETTER MEASURE THE IMPACT OF
EXISTING SERVICES. AND HELP TO
PLACE WORKERS INTO APPROPRIATE.
JOBS AND SERVICES. NO NO LET ME
SUM UP. ROUTE INFORMATION ON
HOURS AND LOCATION WOULD ALLOW
US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
EFFECT OF CHANGES IN THE LABOR
MARKET. AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND TO FURTHER
IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
EDUCATION AND TRAINING SYSTEMS.
TO REALLY PREPARE CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE. FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND YOU KNOW. LIMIT
INEQUALITY AND POVERTY.
INFORMATION ON LOCATION OF
MARKET DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS WILL ALLOW US TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHO BENEFITS
FROM TRAINING HOW TO FURTHER
IMPROVE TRAINING DELIVERY AND
WHO'S BEING MOST AFFECTED BY
CHANGES IN THE LABOR MARKET. NOW
GIVEN THE STAGGERING IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC ON THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR MARKET IN PARTICULAR. ON
JOBS FOR LOWER AND MIDDLE INCOME
WORKERS. I BELIEVE THERE IS A
SENSE OF URGENCY TO MOVE FORWARD
TO ENHANCE CALIFORNIA'S. U. I.
BASE WHICH FILE. AND THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT OTHER STATES HAVE
DELIVERED A BLUEPRINT ON HOW TO
DO IT- SOME EXPERIENCE ON HOW TO
DO OUTREACH. FOR EXAMPLE OR HOW
TO INVOLVE PAYROLL PROCESSES.
AND I THINK NOW THAT THE WORST
OF THE PANDEMIC IS BEHIND US IT
MAY BE JUST THE RIGHT MOMENT WE
HAVE TO ACT ON YOU I BASICALLY.
THANK YOU. SO WE JUST ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN ANSWER THIS BUT DO
YOU KNOW HOW FAR OFF BASE WE
ACTUALLY ARE IN TERMS OF
CONNECTING THE DOTS BETWEEN THE
JOB TRAINING WE PROVIDE. AND THE
JOBS THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY SECURE.
YES A VERY GOOD QUESTION AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND I ONLY
HAVE A PARTIAL ANSWER IN THE
SENSE THAT. YEAH BUT THE TEMPO
TO THIS EARLIER. SEVERAL OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT BE EVALUATED IN
THE COUNCIL STATUS USING
QUARTERLY EARNINGS WHICH BY THE
WAY THAT'S THE INDUSTRY STANDARD
FOR ANY EVALUATION FOR ANY STATE
OR THE FEDERAL LEVEL. FOR
TRAINING PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE EFFECTIVE
AND RAISING WAGES. RIGHT OKAY I
SHOULD SAY THIS EXACTLY FOUNDER
EFFECT OF IT RAISING EARNINGS
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY
EFFECTIVELY RAISE WAGES OR THEY
EFFECTIVELY RAVES ALWAYS WORKS
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
WORKERS ARE ACTUALLY GETTING.
BETTER JOBS RIGHT OR WHETHER
THEY'RE WORKING MORE AND THAT'S
JUST A CRUCIAL DISTINCTION WE
ALSO DON'T REALLY KNOW AT LEAST
FROM. THOSE DATA RIGHT WHETHER
WORKERS ACTUALLY END UP IN AN
OCCUPATION THEY WERE TRAINED FOR-
NOW. THERE IS OTHER INFORMATION
COLLECTED BY THE TRAINING
PROVIDERS THAT IS CAN BE USED TO
ASSESS THAT QUESTION BUT WHAT WE
CANNOT DO. IS DO THAT ANALYSIS
COMPREHENSIVELY ACROSS ALL
TRAINING PROVIDERS ARE ACROSS
ALL WORKERS OR LOCATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING ALWAYS WORK OR WE'RE
NOT COLLECTING OCCUPATION. WHICH
IS THE ISSUE WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRAINING PROGRAMS THE-
THE RESULTS STATED TENDS TO BE
ANECDOTAL. IN PARTICULAR REGIONS
WHERE RELATIONSHIPS ALL OF THE
DATA FLOW TO GO BOTH WAYS I
ASSUME. AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY WHAT YOU MUST BE
TALKING ABOUT SIR. WELL THERE IS
IN OTHER WAYS TO GET INFORMATION
ABOUT YOUR DEBT TO ACCEPTANCE OF
TRAINING WHEN I'M I'M TALKING
ABOUT. ESSENTIALLY STATISTICAL
EVALUATION FOR EXAMPLE OF
WHETHER A PARTICULAR. YOU CAN
PROGRAM A TRAINING PROGRAM
RAISES THE OUTCOME OF THE
WORKERS ATTENDING IT NEXT OFTEN
DONE WE ARE SEPARATE TREATMENT
CONTROL COMPARISON. AND THEN ONE
NEEDS AN OTCOME AND WHAT COULD
USE VARIOUS OUTCOMES ARE. OFTEN
ONE NEEDS VERY LARGE DATASETS TO
EFFECTIVELY DO SUCH A
STATISTICAL TREATMENT CONTROL
COMPARISON ANDY WHY BASE WHICH
FILE IS USUALLY THE GO TO PLACE
TO DO THAT. IN THE ABSENCE TO DO
TO ACTUALLY GET SUCH A
STATISTICAL MEASURE
EFFECTIVENESS THERE ARE WAYS TO
DOING EITHER YOU KNOW INTERVIEWS
OF CASE WORKERS OR DATA
COLLECTIONS THROUGH EXIT
INTERVIEWS OR- SURVEYS THAT CAN
YOU KNOW GET A FINE GRAIN VIEW
ON THE GROUND OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING. IT JUST GETS MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT TO AGGREGATE THAT
UP AND TOOK IT TO GET A BIRD'S
EYE VIEW RIGHT OFF OF WHERE WE
ARE AT DOES IT MAKE MORE SENSE
YES AND TO ACCOMPLISH SIMPLY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT I ASSUME. IN THE
STATE OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
AS DIVERSE AND LARGE IS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS WHEN
YOU'RE HAVING DO IT RUNNING IN
IT WHAT WE WOULD CALL IN
POLITICS A GROUND GAME. AS
OPPOSED TO CENTRALIZED DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS. WELL I
THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE DONE A
LOT OF WORK AND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH. MANY TRAINING PROVIDERS
AND EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
THEY DO INVALUABLE WORK IN
COLLECTING DATA. CAN I VIEW
THESE VARIOUS EFFORTS TO COLLECT
DATA AS COMPLEMENTARY. AND MY
POINT IS WE'RE MISSING AN
IMPORTANT PIECE. IS A
STANDARDIZED COLLECTION OF DATA
THAT ALLOWS US TO COMPUTE HOURLY
WAGES AND UNDERSTAND WHICH
OCCUPATION INDIVIDUALS GET. AND
THAT WOULD COMPLEMENTALL THE
DETAILED KNOWLEDGE UNDERGROUND
DATA TRAINING PROVIDERS
CURRENTLY HAVE. NO I DON'T KNOW
I HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION I'M NOT
SURE FROM YOUR VANTAGE POINT IF
YOU CAN ADDRESS THIS BUT- SHOULD
WE DECIDE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ENHANCED DATA COLLECTION THE
BASE WAGE FILE WHATEVER. WHAT
POTENTIAL- IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
AND COST ELEMENTS. HAVE YOU SEEN
IN THE PAST. WITH EFFORTS SUCH
AS THAT. HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU
HAVE- IT DIDN'T- IT IT GETS
OFTEN INTO THE VERY NITTY
GRITTY- AT OF WHAT HAPPENS ON
THE GROUND AS THIS DATA IS
COLLECTED AND WHEN WE USE THESE
DATA WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME TO
REALLY FOLLOW BACK THE PIPELINE.
FROM WHEN A PERSON SORT OF FILLS
IN AN ELECTRONIC DATA SHEET TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE MEASUREMENT
ISSUES WORK NOW. I GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE- WHAT SINCE WE WERE
INTERESTED IN HOURS WORK- AT
SOME POINT. WE CONTACTED. PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
WEAPON COLLECTING HOURS WORK FOR
QUITE A WHILE AND THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION WAS. ISN'T IT HARD FOR
BUSINESSES TO FIGURE OUT ON A
WEEKLY BASIS HOW MANY HOURS
THERE ARE. MARKERS WORK WOULDN'T
DAY EITHER ALL GIVE FORTY HOURS
WHICH IS FULL TIME OR TWENTY
HOURS SAY WHICH PART TIME OR OR
NOT SO IN THIS INFORMATION. SO
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
NOISE IN THE STATE EYES IS BEING
COLLECTED. WHERE THE NOISE WOULD
REFLECT PARTLY THE COST AND THE
EFFORT. THAT THE EMPLOYERS WOULD
FACE IN IN IN PROVIDING THE
STATUS IT TURNED OUT THAT. THE
DATA ON OURS COLLECTED IN THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON IT'S A VERY
HIGH QUALITY AND IT COMES NOT
ONLY FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE FOLKS ON THE GROUND
COLLECTING THIS DATA. THEY ARE
KIND OF PART OF THE E. D. IN
WASHINGTON STATE BUT ALSO OF THE
RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON USING THE
OUR STATE. SO NOW GIVEN THEY
HAVE OUR STATE AND WE NOW KNOW A
LOT OF IMPORTANT THINGS ABOUT
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON. THAT
I'D LOVE TO KNOW ABOUT
CALIFORNIA BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE OUR STATE
OUT AND IT LOOKS LIKE. IT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE RELATIVELY STRAIGHT
FORWARD TO- COLLECT. VERY
INTERESTING AND I SUPPOSE
CONTACT WITH THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON OR OREGON COULD GIVE
US SOME. FINANCIAL DATA ON THE
COST OF ANY SYSTEMS.
MODIFICATIONS THAT THOSE STATES
HAD TO GO THROUGH IN ORDER TO
CONVENTIONALLY EXPAND THE- THE
BASE WAGE BASE WAGE FILE. I
THINK SO AND I THINK- YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE EXISTING.
NETWORKS AND RAMIFICATIONS SUCH
AS YOU KNOW DR SAXONS NETWORKS
BUT ALSO THEIR DIRECT CONTACT
THAT. MANY OF THE EDT I BELIEVE
HALF TO DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND-
I KNOW I HAD BEEN IN TOUCH WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN AND ARE
YOU I. AGENCY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ANOTHER PROGRAM. CALLED WORK
SCHERING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
WERE DOING ON OUTREACH AND
MICHIGAN HAD JUST A STAGGERING
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROGRAM.
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND NEED
ALONE BEHOLD THEY HAVE A WHOLE
BLUEPRINT ON HOW TO DO OUTREACH
ON THESE ISSUES AND WILL BE JUST
INTERESTING TO SEE. YOU KNOW
WHAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING IN
THIS SPACE. EXCELLENT SERVER
FORGOTTEN TO ASK YOU SOMETHING
THAT I SHOULD'VE. NO YOU HAVEN'T
THANKS FOR YOUR UESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION VERY ENLIGHTENING
AND APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND
KEEP DOING IT WE REALLY BENEFIT
FROM IT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME. WELL WE
FINISHED OUR- TWO PANEL GROUPS
WERE NOT GOING TO MOVE INTO THE
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. DUE TO
ONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. THE CENTRE AUTHORIZES
COMMITTEE CHAIRS TO INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY- I AM
GOING TO TRY NOT TO DO THAT AT
THIS POINT LET'S SEE HOW MANY
CALLERS WE ACTUALLY HAVE I
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO IMPOSE TIME
LIMITS AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH.
PUBLIC COMMENT SO LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS WE
WILL BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
YOUR NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
ONE NINE ZERO FOUR COMMENTS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A COMMENT. FROM
LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI AM I IN THE NEW ECONOMY
AND CAREER TECHNOLOGY HEARING IN
THE SENATE I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE I'M IN THE RIGHT PLACE
BECAUSE- I TRIED TO CALL A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND THERE WAS
NO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE COURT
HEARING AND- SOMETIMES FLIP
PHONES DON'T GO THROUGH. IT IS
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE. THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE MEMBERS
YOU MAY HAVE BEEN. ATTEMPTING TO
CALL THE ASSEMBLY. COMMITTEE
THIS IS A- NATIONAL HEARING OVER
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CAREER
TECHNOLOGY IN THE NEW ECONOMY.
WELL ACTUALLY I'M I'M IN THE
RIGHT PLACE BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO THIS HEARING IT AS
MUCH AS I POSSIBLY CAN-
THROUGHOUT. THE COURSE OF THE
AFTERNOON AND I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF- COMMENTS- OUR OR
MAYBE QUESTION BECAUSE IT IS
MORE OF A Q. ANY. PANEL OR
FORMAT OR IS THIS JUST MORE LIKE
ME MAKING MY OWN SORT OF
OBSERVATION. REMEMBER A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THE
PEOPLE STILL ON THE LINE MA'AM
MA'AM NO MA'AM THIS IS PUBLIC
COMMENT IS NOT DESIGNED FOR
QUESTIONS. OF THE PANELISTS
STORE. INDIVIDUALS ON THE DYESS
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK BRIEFLY.
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER THAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING SO YOU ARE. ON
THE LINE AND YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BRIEFLY
ABOUT OUR SUBJECT MATTER TODAY
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY I WILL.
MAKE AN OBSERVATION ABOUT THESE
PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE HAVING A
COMMENT AND WEIGH IN AS I
APPEARANCE EXPERTS FROM THE EDT.
AND I'M JUST PERPLEXED BECAUSE
WHAT ABOUT THE THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN FRAUD. AND YOU WANT
THEM TO LIKE REPORT TO YOU ABOUT
LIKE UPGRADING THEIR COMPUTER
SYSTEMS AND COLLECTING DATA WHEN
THEY CAN'T EVEN LIKE. PAY OUT
THE CLAIMS TO PEOPLE THAT- AND
YET THEY'RE PAYING OUT THE SORT
OF FRAUDULENT ACCOUNTS. IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE A VERY WALKS ON ME
THAT THIS IS SORT OF LIKE- THIS
LEVEL OF NAVEL GAZING AND- YOU
KNOW CORRUPT ENTITIES POLICING
THEMSELVES MAKES SENSE TO ME.
AND THEN YOU GET A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR AND SUPPOSE
THAT EXPERT ON THERE AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU HOW LIKE
MORE JOB OPENINGS- THAT- YOU
HAVE MORE UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE THAN
THERE ARE JOB OPENINGS. WHAT
PEOPLE DOING DOWN THERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND THEN YOU'VE GOT-
SHOT AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ISSUE AND YOU'RE CREATING YOU'RE
CREATING A JOB. PROBLEM WITH
THESE UNCONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE.
I MEAN IT JUST SEEMS LIKE A
BIGGER THAN THAN TYPICAL
SEPARATE CIRCUITS OF CORRUPTION
TODAY AND I DO LISTEN TO A LOT
OF THE CORRUPTION FROM YOU KNOW
PATRICK O'DONNELL IN THE SHOWER.
WITH THE HORROR THE HORROR. YEAH
EIGHT SHOULD LIKE HI OF A NEW
LEVEL OF- IN SANTA ANITA THERE
TODAY. SO I GUESS I DON'T REALLY
HAVE MUCH TO SAY BEYOND NOW
BECAUSE I'M HAVING TO TALK TO
YOU FROM WORK YOU KNOW WHERE I
WANT TO BE HER FAULT. AND YOU
KNOW IT IT IT COULD BE YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE OTHER- HEARING THAT.
YEAH I JUST THINK IT'S A LOSS
FOR WORDS BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEN
YOU WANT TO COMPARE A WASHINGTON
STATE YOU KNOW TO CALIFORNIA
LIKE APPLES AND ORANGES LIKE SIX
MILLION PEOPLE IN A STATE PERSON
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE. I MEAN I
COULD GO ON AND ON I MEAN I
APPRECIATE YOU'RE NOT CUTTING
OFF BECAUSE I THINK I THINK YOU
GET MY POINT BUT- THIS SEEMS
LIKE THE BLIND LEADING THE BLIND
DOWN THERE YOU KNOW YOU
LEGISLATORS THAT ARE GREASING
YOUR PALMS APARTMENT LED MANY.
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO KICK THE
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL. AND THEN YOU
WONDER WHY LIKE. WHY YOU KNOW.
ARE CAL. BY THE YOU KNOW. OF
DOLLARS AND- WELL I GUESS. I
KIND OF LIKE LEHMAN
OBSERVATIONS. ON A TUESDAY
AFTERNOON AND IT LOCKED ON YOU
THAT THERE WERE TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE DOWN THERE YESTERDAY ON
THE LAWN. PRO TESTING THESE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ACT MANDATES.
THAT ARE GOING TO LIKE CREATE
MORE AND MORE PROBLEMS IN TERMS
OF THE JOB MARKET DOWN. THERE
ARE YOU KNOW IN SACRAMENTO AND
REALLY BUT MORE BROADLY IN
CALIFORNIA. IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
PEOPLE CAN'T GET YOUR DUCKS IN A
ROW. AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SOLUTION IS BUT I JUST FEEL
COMPELLED TO CALIFORNIA AND- TO
KEEP LISTENING AND- KEEP CALLING
IN. TO KEEP SPEAKING MY TRUTH
WHERE I CAN I MEAN I'M NO EXPERT
OBVIOUSLY BUT FROM YOU SENATOR
WHAT ROCK WANTING TO LIKE
STRIPPED THE MIDWIVES OF THEIR
ECONOMY. FORCING THE SHOPS IN
THESE CHILDREN DON'T PEOPLE
ALREADY HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS ON
YOUR HANDS WITHOUT ENTRUSTING
THE EDT. CAN POLICE ITSELF AND
TRY TO EXPAND DATA COLLECTING OR
WHATEVER OTHER NONSENSE YOU
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TRY TO COME
UP WITH. I KNOW THAT'S ALL I
HAVE FOR TODAY AND I APPRECIATE
YOU TALKING TO ME. BUT I THINK
YOU GUYS YOU REALLY NEED TO GET
A GRIP ON THINGS BECAUSE IT'S
NOT WORKING. BUT WE'LL TRY TO DO
THAT THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING.
MA'AM YOU HAVE A GOOD DAY NEXT
PLEASE. ALL RIGHT TO THEIR NO.
IN Q. ONE TWO THAT. ONE OF THE.
ZERO FOR. AND I DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND
THANK YOU TO OUR PARTICIPANTS
AND OUR PANELISTS FOR
PARTICIPATING WANNA THANK THE
PUBLIC MEMBER WHO CALLED IN TO
COMMENT THE DISCUSSION WAS
EXCELLENT TODAY WE CERTAINLY
HAVE OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US
BUT- I THINK I CAN SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CHALLENGE.
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO TRY TO FIX THIS AND GET THIS
RIGHT THE RESIDENTS OF THIS
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
CERTAINLY DEPENDING ON US AND WE
NEED TO STEP UP TO THE TASK. TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED IN
TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AND WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO CONNECT FOR SOME REASON
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OF THIS
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO MY
STAFF MEMBER GILBERT MARTINEZ.
IN ROOM TWENTY EIGHTY HERE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO INCLUDE. YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AGAIN THANKS TO
ALL WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
TODAY. THIS SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.